Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Episode 33, Design Patterns. Take it away patrick so i was watching the live launch of the newest spacex uh flight going to the space station oh nice the dragon capsule and uh it was like at work i felt like it was momentous we were all standing around my monitor and like watching the the rocket lift off and everything um and they had said it was not a main mission objective but the first
本节目由Host Tornado赞助。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和VPS解决方案。HostT.net。第33集，设计模式。帕特里克，开始吧。我当时正在看SpaceX最新一次飞往空间站的发射直播，感觉太棒了。龙飞船，当时我在工作，感觉那一刻意义非凡，我们都站在我的显示器前，看着火箭升空等等。他们说这不是主要任务目标，但第一
stage the you know big rocket part is supposed was supposed to you know come back and try to land uh you know and they want to eventually reuse it but they said it didn't have a large chance of success so i was i was hoping to be able to watch this thing come back down but they didn't have any video whatsoever of that part of it for unknown reasons and it took until like just recently that they this is like you know it launched like last week and then this week they just finally announced that it did successfully do that part of the mission where it deployed these like lander legs from the first stage and then hovered briefly above the ocean and then fell into the ocean. But because the seas were really bad, it got destroyed in the ocean.
级，你知道，那个大火箭部分，本应该，你知道，回来并尝试着陆，你知道，他们最终想重复使用它，但他们说成功的几率不大。所以我当时很希望能看到它回来，但由于未知原因，他们完全没有那部分的视频。直到最近，也就是上周发射，这周他们才终于宣布，它确实成功完成了任务的那一部分，部署了第一级的着陆腿，然后在海洋上空短暂悬停，接着掉进了海里。但因为海况非常糟糕，它在海里被毁了。
Oh no. So you can launch something like the thing that launches something up to space, recover it with rocket engines to slow down, but then the ocean water can destroy it. It's like, Oh, so a couple of things on this one.
噢，不。所以你可以发射像那种把东西送入太空的东西，用火箭发动机减速回收它，但海水却能把它毁掉。就像是，噢，这件事有几点值得注意。
Uh, I heard this crazy story that I guess it's not that crazy, but the idea is like helium, I guess there's a finite amount of helium. You can correct me if I'm wrong here, on Earth at least. Yeah. And I guess helium, liquid helium is necessary for getting to orbit. I think liquid hydrogen. Oh, but helium has something to do with it.
呃，我听过一个疯狂的故事，我想这其实没那么疯狂，但想法是关于氦气，我想地球上的氦气是有限的。如果我说错了，你可以纠正我，至少在地球上是这样。是的。我想氦气，液氦对于进入轨道是必要的。我想是液氢。噢，但氦气和它有某种关系。
Anyways, the way this story went is that basically you need helium at some part at some level and uh if we used up all the helium on things like balloons or whatever that basically would never be able to go into space i've never heard that before oh really yeah i thought it's kind of ridiculous so there is a problem with like there is true helium and like they use it a lot because it's really cold and less dangerous than liquid hydrogen. So they use it for a lot of medical procedures and medical research. And so I know, like, that is a problem. Oh, I see.
总之，这个故事的走向是，基本上你在某个部分、某个层面上需要氦气，呃，如果我们把氦气都用在气球之类的东西上，基本上就永远无法进入太空了。我以前从未听说过。噢，真的吗？是的，我觉得这有点荒谬。所以确实存在问题，比如有真正的氦气，而且他们用得很多，因为它非常冷，而且比液氢危险性小。所以他们把它用于许多医疗程序和医学研究。所以我知道，这确实是个问题。噢，我明白了。
But I've never heard that we couldn't go to space anymore. That might be true. I don't know. Oh, I don't know. It's just kind of crazy. But, of course, then there's always this caveat that if we ever start doing large-scale fusion, you'll most likely have an overabundance of crazy. But of course, then there's always this caveat that if we ever start doing large-scale fusion, you'll most likely have an overabundance of helium.
但我从未听说过我们不能再进入太空了。那可能是真的。我不知道。噢，我不知道。这有点疯狂。但是，当然，总有这样一个警告，如果我们开始进行大规模核聚变，你很可能会有极其过剩的氦气。但是，当然，总有这样一个警告，如果我们开始进行大规模核聚变，你很可能会有极其过剩的氦气。
Oh, that's true. The other thing I was going to say is that there was this article on SpaceX where I guess Elon Musk is suing the government, which, anyway, that's a side note, but I don't understand how you can do that. But basically, at any rate, he's suing the government because they had this like special they had this contract with a joint venture of lockheed and boeing to to do the uh you know the satellites and they wouldn't let him bid and so he's suing you know on the grounds that he should at least be able to compete and bid on this on this project yeah they're doing a lot of stuff i don't a lot of people
噢，那是真的。我要说的另一件事是，有一篇关于SpaceX的文章，我想埃隆·马斯克正在起诉政府，不管怎样，这只是个旁注，我不明白你怎么能那样做。但基本上，无论如何，他起诉政府是因为他们有一个特殊的合同，他们与洛克希德和波音的合资企业签订了合同，来做，你知道，卫星，他们不让他投标，所以他起诉了，你知道，理由是他至少应该有权竞争和投标这个项目。是的，他们正在做很多事情，我不知道，很多人
have very strong feelings about it especially being from florida where a lot of people were employed by nasa and it's uh subsidy not subsidiaries but people who worked for nasa and with nasa right um but yeah the stuff they're doing is really kind of crazy like this rocket recovery where i was kind of going with is like this fact that you could reuse this stage one part of a rocket that's like a giant way to drive down costs if you can do it reliably and with not it being a much more expensive thing in the first place so is that really a big part of the cost the destruction of the bottom it depends right so it's like probably not i don't know but if you're trying to get costs down and down and down i mean just from the
对此有非常强烈的感受，特别是在佛罗里达州，那里很多人受雇于NASA，它是，呃，补贴，不是子公司，而是为NASA工作和与NASA合作的人，对吧。嗯，但他们正在做的事情确实有点疯狂，比如这个火箭回收，我刚才想说的是，事实上你可以重复使用火箭的第一级，如果你能可靠地做到这一点，而且它本身不是一个更昂贵的东西，那将是降低成本的巨大途径。所以这真的是成本的一大部分吗，底部的损毁？这取决于情况，对吧？所以可能不是，我不知道，但如果你想不断降低成本，我的意思是，仅仅从
standpoint of it's a complicated high tolerance thing that you have to build low tolerance high tolerance you have to have small tolerances it has to be very precisely built so no matter what it's going to be expensive to build. And if you can spend just a little bit more and then reuse it several times, it's obviously better, right? Yeah. It's like the argument of like you can buy cheap shoes, but they'll fall apart. If you spend only a little bit more and get nice shoes, they'll last a lot longer.
它是一个复杂的、高公差的东西，你必须制造它的角度来看，低公差、高公差，你必须有很小的公差，它必须非常精确地制造，所以无论如何，制造它都会很昂贵。如果你能多花一点点钱，然后重复使用它几次，显然更好，对吧？是的。这就像买便宜鞋子的论点，但它们会散架。如果你只多花一点点钱买双好鞋，它们会耐用得多。
Yeah, right. But you don't necessarily spend 10 times as much because those shoes don't necessarily last even 10 times longer. Yeah, you get diminishing returns. Yeah. So I think that that's the idea but the fact that it's just kind of crazy it has like these fold down legs and you know does a deceleration burn and like all of that is just crazy yeah it's totally awesome yeah did you ever get into like building model rockets and shooting them in the sky or anything like that i mean we did it several times and i wish i would have done more of it but it's one of those things like where do you go to do it and half the time
是的，没错。但你不一定非要多花10倍的钱，因为那些鞋子不一定能耐用10倍。是的，你会得到边际递减效应。是的。所以我认为这就是那个想法，但它有这些折叠腿，你知道，进行减速燃烧，所有这些都太疯狂了。是的，这太棒了。是的，你有没有尝试过制作模型火箭并把它们射向天空之类的？我的意思是，我们做过几次，我希望我能多做一些，但这是那种你不知道去哪里做的事情，而且有一半的时间
we could never get back the rocket i guess that is a problem isn't it yeah so like you know in florida we had some places but you know i was thinking about stuff here in like silicon valley area i'm sure if you went far enough away but i don't have any idea if I wanted to take my kids out to do model rockets. You can't go to the park. I don't think people would be happy with you. No, I'm pretty sure you can't shoot off model rockets. Not everybody agrees. So where would you go?
我们永远找不回火箭。我想那确实是个问题，不是吗？是的，所以，你知道，在佛罗里达我们有一些地方，但你知道，我正在考虑硅谷地区的东西，我敢肯定如果你走得足够远，但我不知道如果我想带我的孩子去玩模型火箭该去哪。你不能去公园。我不认为人们会对此感到高兴。不，我很确定你不能发射模型火箭。不是每个人都同意。那么你会去哪里呢？
I'd have to drive out of town to do it. Go wherever the Mythbusters go. They're actually based in San Francisco, so they must go somewhere around here. But I think they're actually based in san francisco so they they must go somewhere yeah somewhere but i think they get special permission and i don't know like yeah that's true it's like i do know a couple places that allow you to fly rc airplanes which is also which is nice but um even then like you know in florida i had enough space i could have flown it in my yard like a very small one or whatever but i don't have a yard here right right can you can you fly rc airplanes at any kite flying zone or no
我得开车出城去玩。去“流言终结者”去的地方。他们实际上总部在旧金山，所以他们一定在附近某个地方。但我认为他们实际上总部在旧金山，所以他们一定在某个地方，是的，某个地方，但我认为他们得到了特别许可，我不知道，就像，是的，那是真的，我知道有几个地方允许你放遥控飞机，这也不错，但嗯，即便如此，你知道，在佛罗里达我有足够的空间，我可以在我的院子里放飞它，一个非常小的或者什么的，但我这里没有院子，对吧，对吧，你可以在任何风筝飞行区放遥控飞机吗，还是不行？
i mean so it's a whole bunch of rules and then there's like what's legal and what's nice i see so it's like if other people are flying kites you probably don't want to um and then like when you get a certain sizeites, you probably don't want to. And then like when you get to a certain size and stuff, you're kind of supposed to get permissions and licenses and that kind of stuff. So you're saying I shouldn't fly like a drone with a Kinect on it over my neighbor's backyard? I'm saying legally you probably could, but you might make them mad. Oh, I see. So I think the Fa recently passed something like
我的意思是，这有一大堆规则，然后还有什么是合法的，什么是好的。我明白了，所以如果别人在放风筝，你可能不想，然后当你达到一定尺寸时，你可能不想。然后当你达到一定尺寸之类的，你得去获得许可和执照之类的东西。所以你是说我不应该在邻居的后院上空放一架带Kinect的无人机？我是说从法律上讲你可能可以，但你可能会让他们生气。噢，我明白了。所以我认为联邦航空局最近通过了一些关于
for non-commercial use uh below a certain level like they said it was okay or whatever oh really you have to have i think you have to have line of sight and below i don't i i really can't remember now but there's some ruling where yeah basically it's okay, yeah, don't do it commercially. That's still not completely okay. And if it ever crashes in your neighbor's yard, they might not be very happy with you. Yeah, right. So the first news item I had was I came across this giant list.
非商业用途的东西，呃，在一定水平以下，比如他们说没问题之类的。噢，真的吗？你必须有，我想你必须有视线，并且在以下，我不，我真的记不清了，但有一些裁决，基本上没问题，是的，不要商业化。那仍然不完全没问题。如果它撞在邻居的院子里，他们可能不会很高兴。是的，没错。所以我的第一个新闻项目是我偶然发现了一个巨大的列表。
That's the only way I can describe it. It's a giant list of free programming books so it's a github site repository i think it's and i don't think it's a whole repository but the repository is literally just a huge amount of links yeah yeah i think it's just so people can like branch it and update it and make edits to it i'm not sure why it's not a wiki um i'm not exactly sure anyways other than like that other people could branch it and make their own alterations that they didn't want to necessarily share back but it's got like all the programming languages uh different topics and then under each heading there's you know at least one or two books and some many more um and
这是我能描述它的唯一方式。这是一个巨大的免费编程书籍列表，所以它是一个GitHub存储库，我想，我不认为它是一个完整的存储库，但存储库里字面上全是大量的链接。是的，是的，我想这只是为了让人们可以分支它、更新它并进行编辑。我不确定为什么它不是一个维基，我不完全确定，总之，除了其他人可以分支它并进行他们不一定想分享回去的修改之外，它有所有的编程语言，呃，不同的主题，然后在每个标题下，你知道，至少有一两本书，有些更多，嗯，而且
so some of the books are kind of like some guy wrote this and then other ones are published books that just got permission to be released for free. But we'll post the link in the show notes or you can search it free programming books GitHub and it should come up. I would recommend you take a look if there's a topic you're interested in learning about.
所以有些书就像是某个人写的，然后其他的则是已经获得许可免费发布的出版书籍。但我们会把链接贴在节目说明里，或者你可以搜索“免费编程书籍 GitHub”，它应该会出现。如果你有感兴趣的主题想学习，我建议你看一看。
Yeah, if you search for GitHub books, it's the fifth result which is pretty remarkable on your on your on your account uh oh yeah well let me try anonymously okay well needless to say you should be able to find it or you can just look at the show notes you're right it's actually the third result if you search anonymous oh that's like uh if you search search java do you get coffee or the programming language well it depends if you're using google i guess it depends on what you also searched before yeah that makes sense yeah cool okay um so so mine is pretty dorky, but I thought it was pretty cool. Basically, Russ Cox, who's one of the founding members of the Go language team, he decided to port the Go compiler to Go. So originally they wrote the Go compiler in, I think, C or C++? Or in C. And so he argues that the reason why
是的，如果你搜索“GitHub 书籍”，它是第五个结果，这在你的账户上非常引人注目。噢，是的，好吧，让我匿名试试。好吧，不用说，你应该能找到它，或者你可以直接看节目说明。你是对的，如果你匿名搜索，它实际上是第三个结果。噢，那就像，呃，如果你搜索“Java”，你得到的是咖啡还是编程语言？好吧，这取决于你是否在使用谷歌，我想这取决于你之前还搜索了什么。是的，这说得通。是的，酷，好吧，嗯，所以我的那个相当书呆子气，但我觉得它很酷。基本上，Russ Cox，Go语言团队的创始成员之一，他决定将Go编译器移植到Go。所以最初他们用，我想，C或C++编写了Go编译器？或者用C。所以他认为，我们用C编写它的原因是
we wrote it in C is because we didn't have Go. And so to back up that argument, he actually, they wrote, I guess they wrote a program that transpiled C to Go. And that got them 90% of the way there. But then there were like go-to's in the code and things like that which didn't translate as well you know i i just gotta say like if someone's inventing a language and they use go-to's like that worries me like it makes me worried about using the language but i i do think go is an amazing language even though the person it's not wait the go had go to's or the c had go to's well the c implementation of the go compiler had go to's oh um was it auto generated parts or somebody actually wrote go to code no you said there's 1032 go to statements i've never come across a go-to statement in any crc++ code i've ever
因为我们没有Go。为了支持这个论点，他实际上，他们写了一个程序，将C转译为Go。这让他们完成了90%。但后来代码里有goto之类的东西，翻译得不太好。你知道，我不得不说，如果有人发明一种语言，他们使用goto，这让我担心，这让我担心使用这种语言。但我确实认为Go是一门了不起的语言，尽管那个人，等等，Go有goto还是C有goto？好吧，Go编译器的C实现有goto。噢，嗯，那是自动生成的代码还是有人真的写了goto代码？不，你说有1032个goto语句。我从来没在我看过的任何C/C++代码中遇到过goto语句。
looked at uh no no i mean like i see examples of it like on the internet right like in code that i've worked in and repositories i've worked i've never seen a go-to statement not once i have seen it very rarely and has always been terrible terrible code like i've always looked at it and kind of kind of just shook my head like i actually had a discussion with someone on my team about how we could avoid a lot of problems by using go to and they didn't even want to hear it and i was you know it's generally i guess considered bad to use go to but like anything it's just a tool and it got misused a bunch and yeah i think there are cases where it could be good if you use it right i mean i think that uh i used to agree with that and unless you're using java and you have finally
呃，不，不，我的意思是，我确实在互联网上看到过它的例子，比如在我工作过的代码和存储库中，我从来没见过goto语句，一次都没有。我见过非常少，而且总是糟糕的代码。我总是看着它，摇摇头。我实际上和我的团队里的人讨论过我们如何通过使用goto来避免很多问题，他们甚至不想听。而且你知道，通常我认为使用goto被认为是坏的，但像任何东西一样，它只是一个工具，它被滥用了很多次。是的，我认为在某些情况下，如果你用对了，它可能是好的。我的意思是，我认为，呃，我曾经同意这一点，除非你使用Java并且你有finally。
if you have finally i don't think you need goto you know so like most of the time when I've seen goto used it's always been because wait does java have goto no they don't my argument is that if c++ had finally
如果你有finally，我不认为你需要goto。你知道，所以大多数时候我看到goto被使用，总是因为，等等，Java有goto吗？不，他们没有。我的论点是，如果C++有finally，
like a block of code that would execute you know no matter what happened then that effectively is go to in a sense like yeah yeah so that's mainly the kind of thing i'm thinking of like when i've come across it mostly in c not just c++ but in c a lot of times you get this multi-path return like you're try catching without try catch right and it would be just more convenient instead of the convoluted copy and pasting they do to have a go-to yep that makes sense
就像一段无论发生什么都会执行的代码块，那么从某种意义上说，这实际上就是goto。是的，是的，所以这主要是我想到的那种事情，比如当我遇到它时，大多是在C中，不仅仅是C++，但在C中，很多时候你会得到这种多路径返回，就像你在没有try-catch的情况下进行try-catch，对吧？与其进行他们所做的复杂的复制粘贴，不如有一个goto更方便。是的，这说得通。
but what do I know nothing that's the answer I wrote a bunch of C++ and I'm kind of done with that language I mean unless I really have to I just don't I mean unless we go back to doing you know
但我知道什么？什么都不知道，这就是答案。我写了很多C++，我已经厌倦了那门语言。我的意思是，除非我真的必须，我只是不，我的意思是，除非我们回到做，你知道，
like drivers for robots or something like that or you know image processing for robots i mean i don't really i don't know i just it just never seems to have the things that i want you know and then the build system too is kind of a nightmare unless someone's you know done a lot of infrastructure work for you and stuff like that i used to only do c c++ and i was happy and i thought java was silly then i did only java and then i was like oh okay this isn't too bad now i'm doing c and i wish i could do c++ or java i don't really care but i'm stuck with just c for now for what i'm currently working on. Oh, bummer. Wait, you can't even use C++? No. What?
比如机器人的驱动程序之类的，或者你知道，机器人的图像处理。我的意思是，我真的，我不知道，它似乎从来没有我想要的东西，你知道，而且构建系统也是一场噩梦，除非有人，你知道，为你做了很多基础设施工作之类的。我曾经只做C/C++，我很开心，我觉得Java很傻。然后我只做Java，然后我就想，噢，好吧，这还不算太坏。现在我正在做C，我希望我能做C++或Java，我真的不在乎，但我现在只能做C，为了我目前正在做的事情。噢，真倒霉。等等，你甚至不能用C++？不。什么？
Wait, okay, so I got to know. So, I mean, without going into a lot of detail, like, give me an example, like, at a high level. Like, when, I've never been in a situation where I couldn't use C++. It's just a severely resource-constrained situation, right? But, I mean, even then, like, they both compiled to machine language what's the difference so so part of it is i joined this team when they had already had a decent sized
等等，好吧，所以我得知道。所以，我的意思是，在不深入细节的情况下，给我一个例子，比如，在高层面上。比如，我从来没有遇到过不能使用C++的情况。这只是资源严重受限的情况，对吧？但是，我的意思是，即便如此，它们都编译成机器语言，有什么区别？所以，部分原因是，我加入这个团队时，他们已经有了一个相当大的
code base and they are resistant to switching to c++ or using any c++ because it is true if you're not careful you can have in in our situation the small amount of bloat that you would normally consider small would be very impactful okay um and i i disagree i think we have the space to spare they disagree with me so uh we're stuck using c yeah this is this is my argument against it right and i know i'm kind of preaching to the choir here but it's you know when you use a language like C++ you can because you're kind of working at a higher level you can be more clever with the memory and not end up with the complete mess you know like basically like in C you know you can't you know like for example with C++ you can do placement new and you can put
代码库，他们抵制切换到C++或使用任何C++，因为这是真的，如果你不小心，在我们的情况下，你通常认为很小的那点膨胀会非常有影响。好吧，嗯，我不同意，我认为我们有空间可以节省，他们不同意我的看法，所以我们只能用C。是的，这是我反对它的论点，对吧？我知道我有点在对牛弹琴，但你知道，当你使用像C++这样的语言时，你可以，因为你是在更高层面上工作，你可以更聪明地处理内存，而不会最终陷入一团糟。你知道，基本上就像在C中，你知道，你不能，你知道，例如，用C++你可以做placement new，你可以把
objects in certain spots of memory right and so i wouldn't feel comfortable doing like those kind of hacks and see in regular c and trying to maintain it and keep it all in my head but in c++ i could do it because there's the language is rich enough that if I were to look at the code later I would know what's going on you know yeah I feel like maybe my severely resource constrained severely wasn't emphasized enough perhaps okay fair enough but yeah check this article out
对象放在内存的特定位置，对吧？所以我不会觉得在常规C中做那种黑客行为并试图维护它并把它全部记在脑子里很舒服。但在C++中我可以做到，因为语言足够丰富，如果我以后看代码，我会知道发生了什么，你知道。是的，我觉得也许我“资源严重受限”的“严重”没有被足够强调。好吧，有道理。但是的，看看这篇文章。
it's pretty cool so bootstrapping is that what that's called right writing go and go yeah I think that's what it's called yeah yeah so they actually they're able to write go and go and go yeah i think that's what it's called yeah yeah so they actually they were able to write go and go and uh i always wondered about like how um you know because gcc needs gcc to build and uh i always wondered like if if uh if they go to a brand new machine like like someone invents a whole new architecture,
它很酷，所以引导（bootstrapping），这就是所谓的，对吧？用Go写Go，是的，我想这就是所谓的。是的，是的，所以他们实际上能够用Go写Go，用Go写Go。是的，我想这就是所谓的。是的，是的，所以他们实际上能够用Go写Go，呃，我一直想知道，比如，你知道，因为GCC需要GCC来构建，呃，我一直想知道，如果，如果他们去一台全新的机器，比如有人发明了一种全新的架构，
I guess that person has to write a version of GCC and assembly. Yeah, that's cross-compiling, right? Yeah, you have to compile on one machine for another. You can compile for ARM on a x86 processor. Yeah, so if you go and invent the next one, like the leg processor to compete with ARM, then you have to get it i see what you did there thanks thanks for that then you have to write the gcc in assembly or something or i don't know uh no i don't think so oh you don't have to write all of it right like a lot of it is common you just the code generation part and that's one of the the llvm right the other people is it's like
我想那个人必须写一个GCC版本和汇编。是的，那是交叉编译，对吧？是的，你必须在一台机器上为另一台机器编译。你可以在x86处理器上为ARM编译。是的，所以如果你去发明下一个，比如与ARM竞争的处理器，那么你必须得到，我明白你的意思了。谢谢，谢谢。然后你必须用汇编写GCC或者什么的，或者我不知道。呃，不，我不这么认为。噢，你不必写所有的东西，对吧？很多是通用的，你只需要代码生成部分，这就是LLVM，对吧？其他人，它是，就像
one of the things they're working to make better is you have a bunch of front ends and then you get into an intermediate language and then you do a bunch of whole bunch of other stuff and then at some the very last step is you produce machine code so only that part you would have to rewrite oh i get it and at that point it's probably not that many instructions that you have well i'm not going to say it's not a hard job it's just not as hard not as hard no right right right all right cool learn something new our next article is about i don't actually know how to say the name of this the litro camera litro litro this is originally the one that looked like a large uh lipstick case camera okay that was called a light field camera anyways the next version version 2.0 or whatever it's called something weird
他们正在努力改进的事情之一是，你有一堆前端，然后你进入一种中间语言，然后你做一堆其他事情，最后，最后一步是你生成机器代码，所以只有那部分你必须重写。噢，我明白了，在那一点上，可能没有那么多指令。好吧，我不会说这不是一项艰巨的工作，它只是没那么难，没那么难。不，对，对，对。好吧，酷，学到了新东西。我们的下一篇文章是关于，我实际上不知道怎么说这个名字，Litro相机，Litro，Litro，这最初是看起来像一个大口红盒的相机。好吧，那叫光场相机。总之，下一个版本，2.0版本或者不管它叫什么，奇怪的东西
is coming out and it looks like a just kind of cool point and shoot camera instead of very weird thing and this is the one where you take one picture and it uses what they call light field but basically it takes a whole bunch of different focused images all at once and then later it constructs where everything was in the scene and so you can do refocusing okay so this works kind of like i think it's like the way like a fly's eye works where it has many facets on it and each one has a slightly different view of the scene but then computationally you can come up with had you been at a given point and a given focus what would the scene have look
要出来了，它看起来就像一个很酷的傻瓜相机，而不是非常奇怪的东西。这就是你拍一张照片，它使用他们所说的光场，但基本上它一次拍摄一堆不同的聚焦图像，然后稍后它构建场景中所有东西的位置，所以你可以进行重新聚焦。好吧，所以这工作起来有点像，我想就像苍蝇眼睛工作的方式，它上面有许多小面，每一个对场景都有略微不同的视角，但然后通过计算，你可以得出，如果你在给定的点和给定的焦点，场景会是什么样子
like oh no and so they take one picture but the trade-off is you have less resolution so because you're taking redundant pixels pixels that have redundant information at some level you lose megapixels but you get this other information that's depth information and so there's a whole bunch of neat effects you can do with it like having a really shallow depth of field or having everything in focus um or moving the focus around after the effect and one of the always the i guess two second explanation is you take an image and it's never blurry um or it's never out of focus is what they say it can be blurry because you can still have motion blur but it's never out of focus um which does it look weird i mean because because it's sort of unnatural right like if
噢，不。所以他们拍一张照片，但权衡是你会有更低的分辨率，因为你在拍摄冗余像素，在某种程度上具有冗余信息的像素，你失去了百万像素，但你得到了这种其他信息，即深度信息。所以你可以用它做一堆整洁的效果，比如拥有非常浅的景深，或者让所有东西都聚焦，嗯，或者在效果之后移动焦点。其中一个，我猜是两秒钟的解释，你拍一张图像，它永远不会模糊，或者它永远不会失焦，这就是他们所说的。它可能会模糊，因为你仍然会有运动模糊，但它永远不会失焦。它看起来奇怪吗？我的意思是，因为因为它有点不自然，对吧？比如如果
something was really close and in focus and then the whole background was also in focus that might be jarring right because your eye doesn't really work that way um so i i did a little bit of uh looking at ways of doing strange pictures so there's a lot of times when people actually do do this um so for instance when you take product photography of like a watch, they'll do what's called image stacking. So they take a bunch of pictures at slightly different focus depths and then stack them all together to get a completely everything sharp macro shot of a watch.
某样东西非常近且聚焦，然后整个背景也聚焦，那可能会令人不快，对吧？因为你的眼睛不是那样工作的。所以我做了一点关于做奇怪图片的方法的研究。所以有很多时候人们确实这样做。所以例如，当你拍摄像手表这样的产品摄影时，他们会做所谓的图像堆叠。所以他们拍摄一堆在略微不同焦距深度的照片，然后把它们堆叠在一起，得到一张完全清晰的微距手表照片。
You can see all the details. And it doesn't really look unnatural. Or when you have a scene of like a road stretching see all the details and it doesn't really look unnatural or when you have a scene of like a road stretching off into the distance normally some parts of that would be out of focus because of the constraints of you would need a infinitely small aperture to have everything in focus but infinitely small aperture means you have to have it open for a really long amount of time infinite amount of time so instead there's ways of shifting the plane of what records the image so that the part that's in focus is all the way along the thing that you're actually imaging. That was really bad in
你可以看到所有的细节。它看起来并不真的不自然。或者当你有一个像道路延伸到远处的场景时，通常由于限制，那里的某些部分会失焦，因为你需要一个无限小的光圈来让所有东西都聚焦，但无限小的光圈意味着你必须让它打开很长一段时间，无限长的时间。所以相反，有移动记录图像平面的方法，这样聚焦的部分沿着你实际成像的东西一直延伸。那在词汇上真的很糟糕。
words. I don't know if anyone could follow that. I think I got it. So there are tricks and you can do them and they don't actually look that unnatural. Oh, okay. Because in your eye, you don't necessarily think of things being out of focus because whenever you look at is in focus. Typically. Oh, I see what you're saying. Yeah, because you're not really looking in your periphery like that clearly.
我不知道是否有人能跟上。我想我明白了。所以有一些技巧，你可以使用它们，它们实际上看起来并不那么不自然。噢，好吧。因为在你的眼睛里，你不一定认为东西是失焦的，因为无论你看什么都是聚焦的。通常。噢，我明白你的意思了。是的，因为你并没有真正那样清晰地看你的周边。
It's not possible. So it's almost the reverse, right? The images that have the focus like the depth blur like things that are far away the bokeh or whatever um it's a artistic effect to focus your attention on the thing that's sharp but it doesn't necessarily look more natural oh i gotcha cool cool that makes it it's kind of cool and it's it's a interesting like a long lot of time people have known this light field thing and now they're actually making something that is a consumer device so it's kind of cool to see yeah yeah that's awesome i'm really tongue
这不可能。所以这几乎是相反的，对吧？那些有焦点的图像，比如深度模糊，比如远处的物体，焦外成像（bokeh）之类的，嗯，这是一种艺术效果，用来将你的注意力集中在清晰的东西上，但这不一定看起来更自然。噢，我明白了，酷，酷。这使得它，它有点酷，而且它是一个有趣的，很长一段时间人们都知道这个光场东西，现在他们实际上正在制造一种消费设备，所以看到这个很酷。是的，是的，那太棒了。我今晚真的舌头打结了，我很抱歉。它是像，呃，当你说是像4000美元还是什么荒谬的价格？我想是1200美元左右。好吧。那仍然相当高。是的。对于相机爱好者来说，不算太坏，我想。我猜也许是……噢，实际上是1600美元。它叫Elum。
tied tonight i apologize is it like uh when you say because is it like $4,000 or something ridiculous? I think it's like $1,200. Okay. That's still pretty steep. Yeah. For camera enthusiasts, it's not too bad, I guess. I guess maybe it's the... Oh, it's actually $1,600. And it's called the Elum.
如果你在网上看，他们有一些样本图像，你实际上可以在浏览器中移动。这有点令人沮丧，因为你实际上可以在浏览器中移动，嗯，这有点令人沮丧，因为你不能使用你正常的摄影工具，因为它有一种特殊的格式，嗯，但我，我想这是那种人们称之为特斯拉模式的东西，这就是我听到的。噢，也就是你卖昂贵的小众产品来证明一切，然后随着时间的推移降低价格。是的，没错。我听说新的特斯拉，他们打算尝试把它降到3500美元左右，而不是90000美元。等等，35000美元。
And they have some sample images if you look online that you can actually move around in your browser. And it is kind of a bummer because you can actually move around in your browser um and it is kind of a bummer because you can't use your normal photography tools because it has a special format um but i it's one of those things i guess like people call it the tesla model is what i've heard oh which is you sell the expensive niche thing to prove everything out and then you bring the price down over time yeah right i heard that the the new Tesla, they're going to try to bring it down to like $3,500 instead of $90,000. Wait, $35,000.
我是说35000美元。好吧，好吧。是的，是的，所以那会很酷。如果发生这种情况，我想我们会看到更多的特斯拉。你已经在和你妻子开始那个对话了吗？所以……我需要买一辆电动车，它曾经是特斯拉。是的，我的意思是我们的下一辆车因为孩子现在必须是小型货车，孩子和未来的孩子必须是某种SUV、小型货车之类的。
I mean $35,000. Okay, okay. Yeah. Yeah, so that would be pretty cool. I think we'll see a lot more Teslas if that happens. Are you already starting that conversation with your wife? So... I need to buy an electric car it used to be a tesla yeah i mean our next car because of the kids now have to be a minivan the kid and the future kid have to be has to be some kind of suv minivan something
所以他们确实有那个特斯拉Model X，它应该是一辆SUV，但我不认为那更便宜。是的，是的，那仍然是90000美元的特斯拉。所以35000美元的特斯拉可能还要很多年。是的，所以，是的，我的，呃，我有另一篇新闻文章。它是“日常生活的小窍门”。这是Quora上的一个非常酷的问题。噢，等等，等等，你上集谈过这个，你的Quora回答。你回答了这个吗？
so they do have actually that that tesla model x which is supposed to be a an suv but i don't think that's like cheaper yeah yeah that's still the ninety thousand dollar tesla so thirty five thousand dollar tesla is probably years and years in the future yeah so yeah mine uh i have another news article. It's Hacks for Everyday Life. This is a pretty cool question on Quora. Oh, wait, wait, you talked about this last episode, your Quora answering. Did you answer this one?
没错。什么？我在这个问题上投了几次赞成票。噢，等等，但这些都不是你的回答。都不是我的回答。但我认为这很酷。实际上，第一个是，比如，增强你的谷歌搜索技巧，我，这很酷，嗯，实际上第一个是增强你的谷歌搜索技巧，我觉得没那么酷，但其中一些，比如，呃，有如何打包行李箱，这太神奇了。我的意思是，你试过这些吗？我试过这些，比如如何打包
That's right. What? I upvoted several answers on this question. Oh, wait, but none of these are your answers. None of them are my answer. But I thought this was pretty cool. Actually, the first one is, like, enhancing your Google Foo, which I this was pretty cool um actually the first one is like enhancing your google foo which i thought was less cool um but some of them like uh there's how to pack a suitcase and it's pretty amazing i mean have you ever tried these i've tried these like how to pack
行李箱，是的，从来不像图片里展示的那样工作，比如有这些，有这些小的，呃，比如以特殊方式卷起来，或者放进这些特殊的更小的袋子里。我从来没，我的东西总是最终变得皱巴巴的，我最终在旅行结束时只是把所有东西都扔进去，因为它似乎工作得一样好。噢，有两个关于如何挑选水果的回答，这对我个人来说是一个挣扎。我总是似乎，比如，我随机挑选水果，有时，比如我从商店买的芒果，有时它们很棒，有时它们很干，有时它们，它们太熟了或者不够熟，不管怎样，这只是像几个非常简单的规则。例如，对于草莓，我想它们闻起来有多香告诉你
a suitcase yeah never works like they'd show in the pictures like having these having these little uh like rolling it up in a special way or putting in these special smaller bags i've never they all my stuff always ends up being wrinkled and i end up at the end of the trip just everything's thrown in there because it seems to work just as well oh there's there's two answers both on how to pick fruit which is personally something i struggle with i always seem to like just i randomly pick fruit and sometimes like the mangoes i get from the store sometimes they're great sometimes they're dry sometimes they're like they're overly ripe or not ripe enough whatever and this is just like a few very simple rules like for example for strawberries i guess how much however much they smell tells you
某种程度上它们会有多少味道。所以如果他们之前没注意到，比如如果你闻过成熟草莓的味道，它会让你真的很想吃一个。是的，我的意思是这些是我，我猜我总是很匆忙，从来没有停下来闻。我总是闻东西，人们总是觉得我很奇怪，因为，比如我会拿食物，然后，比如我会把脸凑下去闻它，不是奇怪地，我不认为。是的，不像，呃，《指环王》里的那个家伙，像“宝贝”。噢，不，等等，那个人是谁？他叫什么名字？我完全想不起来了，咕噜。咕噜，是的，是的，不是非常像咕噜的草莓采摘。总之，是的，我确实，我注意到了，所以我真的很喜欢闻我的食物。我
sort of how much taste they'll have so if they don't notice that before like if you ever smell the smell of like a ripe strawberry it makes you really want to eat one yeah i mean these are things i just i guess i was always in a hurry and never like stopped to smell i always smell stuff and people always think i'm weird because like i'll get food and then like i'll you know hold my face down to like smell it not like weirdly i don't think yeah not like uh the guy from lord of the rings like precious oh no wait what who is that guy what's his name i'm totally drawing a golem golem yeah yeah not not very golem-esque strawberry picking up anyways but yes i do i noticed that so i really like smelling my food i
不知道。是的，我的意思是，还有对于，嗯，柑橘类水果，他们说按重量来。如果葡萄柚很重，那就意味着里面有很多汁。所以，我的意思是，再次，它是有道理的，但这是那种如果你不考虑它，你就永远不会做的事情，对吧？所以只是需要有人，比如，教育你，突然之间你就永远不会做，对吧？所以只是需要有人，比如，教育你。突然之间你就想，噢，好吧。所以我去找最重的葡萄柚，然后就完成了。此外，还有一个很酷的回答。你知道那些盒装牛奶吗？
don't know yeah i mean and also for um citrus they said to go by weight like if the grapefruit is heavy that means there's a lot of juice in it so i mean again it's like it makes sense but it's one of these things that like if you don't think about it you're never gonna do it right so just someone needs to like educate you and all of a sudden you're never going to do it, right? So just someone needs to, like, educate you. And all of a sudden you're like, oh, all right. So I'll look for the heaviest grapefruit and be done. Also, there's this cool answer. You know those boxed milks?
比如，不是那种，比如，在纸盒里的，而是那种在真正的盒子里，比如米浆之类的东西。是的，是的，是的，是的。所以这个家伙有这个帖子，基本上如果你用喷嘴朝下的方式倒它，这是最直观的，那么，你知道，空气进不去，这使得它很难倒。但如果你用喷嘴，你知道，在纸盒顶部出来的方式倒它，那么空气总是有机会进去。我不知道，只是那种随机的事情，我觉得它们很酷。是的，好吧，我要试试。它字面上全是这些随机事情的页面和页面。所以，所以自从你读了这个之后，你用得最多的是哪一个？好吧，呃，我昨天读了这个，所以
Like, not the ones, like, in the carton, but the ones in the actual box, like the rice milk and stuff like that. Yes, yes, yes, yes. So this guy has this post where basically if you pour it with the nozzle facing down which is the most intuitive then you know air can't get out and it makes it very hard to pour but if you pour it with the nozzle you know on the top of the carton coming out then the air always gets a chance to go in i don't know just kind of random things like that i thought they were pretty cool yeah okay i'm gonna try that it's literally just pages and pages of these random things so so which one have you used the most since you read this well uh i read this yesterday so
所以没有，嗯，是的，没有一个，但，呃，但我们会看看，希望我，我实际上在五月，你知道，我将能够旅行，你知道，我可能会吃一些柑橘，呃，和，呃，你知道，倒一些米浆之类的，一天之内全部搞定。所以杰森破解了他的生活，敬请期待。是的，没错。是时候介绍本期图书了。本期图书。所以这是一个完全无耻的植入，我应该，我应该对此感到糟糕，但，嗯，我合著了一本书，现在正在上架，它叫《HTML5游戏编程见解》。我和，呃，Colt Mechanis还有一堆其他人一起写的，我写了关于网络编程的那一章。嘿，你的名字在这页上。什么，封面？
so none um yeah none of them but uh but we'll see hopefully i i actually in may you know i'll be able to travel you know i'll maybe eat some citrus and uh and uh you know pour some rice milk or something get it all out in one in one day so jason hacks his life stay tuned yeah that's right time for a book of the show book of the show so this is a total shameless plug i should i should feel terrible about this but um i co-wrote a book that is now hitting the shelves it's called html5 game programming insights i wrote it with uh colt mechanis and a bunch of other people and uh i wrote the chapter on network programming. Hey, your name's on this page. What, the front page?
是的。所以如果你们有兴趣，你知道，为网络编写游戏，一定要看看。有很多非常矮的人为使这本书变得棒极了做出了很多贡献。我真的，你知道，它有很多作者，但我真的很喜欢那样，因为……是的，所以我正要说，作为一本出版书籍的作者，你感觉如何？然后你觉得你必须和，看起来像其他十几个人分享封面，你感觉如何？是的，所以每个人写了一章，我想有12或13章。所以有很多作者。但好的一点是，你知道，我觉得大多数这些书你真的不能写整本书，嗯，你知道，原因是那个要写整本书的人
Yes. So if you guys are interested in, you know, writing games for the web, definitely check it out. There's a lot of really short people who have contributed a lot of work into making this book awesome. I really, you know, it has a lot of authors, but I really like that because... Yeah, so I was going to say, how do you feel about being an author of a published book? And then how do you feel that you have to share the cover with, like, it looks like a dozen other people? Yeah, so each person wrote a chapter and there is, I think, 12 or 13 chapters. So there's a lot of authors. But the good thing is, you know, I feel like most of these books you really can't write a whole book um you know the reason is the person who's going to write an entire
关于，比如，我不知道，Hadoop或者类似的东西，嗯，它要么需要他们花费数年时间，在这种情况下，书已经有点过时了，要么他们没有真正的工作，或者他们可能在休假之类的，在这种情况下，比如他们只是真的在啃书，并没有真正给予它应有的关注，对吧？所以通过让每个人写一章，我能够，比如，一，专注于我真正热衷的事情，也就是你的网络游戏编程，二，比如，你知道，我可以花很多时间在上面，因为它只是，你知道，书的1/12，而不是，你知道，400、500页。恭喜。所以，是的，所以我认为结果非常好。我已经读了几章
book on say i don't know hadoop or something like that um it either is going to take them years and years in which case the book is already kind of dated or they don't really have like a job or they're maybe they're on sabbatical or something in which case like they're just really crunching through the book and not really giving it the attention it deserves right so by having each person write a chapter i was able to like one focus on something i'm really passionate about which is your network game programming and two to like you know i could spend a lot of time on it because it was you know 1 12th of a book and not you know 400 500 pages congratulations so yeah so i think it turned out really well i've read a few of the
其他的章节，我是个大粉丝。是的，总的来说，网页游戏很酷的一点是，给你的朋友和家人链接非常容易。而且，你知道，相比于，如果你在Windows或手机上制作它之类的，那么你必须，比如，经历一堆戏剧性的事情来部署它之类的。所以下次我们和你谈话时，你会变得富有和出名吗？好吧，考虑到我正在和另外12个人分享一本小众书的一小部分版税，我非常怀疑。但我认为我对HTML5的了解肯定比以前多了。我们将在下一集《富人和作者满载的生活方式》中和你谈话。是的。我会用HTML，HTML，在HTML，呃，标签或不，呃，结束标签，标签，太棒了。我不，你写了一本关于HTML的书，你知道，我听到“标签”这个词的频率比“结束标签”多得多，这只是接管了。好吧，但是的，所以，所以一定要去看看，呃，嗯，你知道，让我知道你的想法，如果你发现错误或错别字，给我一些反馈，让我知道。所以，好吧，是的，我的书是我希望我写的，那算吗？那算，你为此获得版税吗？不，我没有。这叫《火星救援》，作者是Andy Weir。Weir？我不知道。Andy。这基本上是，我想，我不会尝试，我会尽量不剧透任何东西，但我想封底说它基本上是火星上的鲁滨逊漂流记。
other chapters i'm a big fan yeah in general the cool thing about web games is that it's very easy to just give the link to your friends and family. And, you know, versus like, if you were to make it on Windows or on the phone or something like that, then you have to like, go through a whole bunch of drama to deploy it and things like that. So will you be rich and famous by the next time we talk to you? Well, considering I'm splitting a small percentage of the royalties with 12 other people on a niche book, I highly doubt it. But I think I am definitely more educated on HTML5 than I was before. We will be talking to you next episode of Lifestyles of the Rich and Full of Authors. Yeah. I'll be talking to you with HTML html in html uh hashtag or no uh closing tag hashtag great i don't you wrote a book on html you know i've heard the word hashtag so much more
其他章节我也很喜欢。总的来说，网页游戏的酷炫之处在于，你可以非常轻松地把链接发给朋友和家人。相比之下，如果你是在 Windows 或手机上开发，就得经历一大堆麻烦的部署流程。那么下次我们再聊时，你会变得富有且出名吗？考虑到我是在一本小众书上与另外 12 个人平分一小部分版税，我非常怀疑。但我认为我对 HTML5 的了解肯定比以前多了。我们下期《富豪与作者生活》节目再聊。好的，我会用 HTML 标签，或者说闭合标签，或者井号，不，是闭合标签，太棒了。你不是写了一本关于 HTML 的书吗？你知道，我听到“井号”这个词的频率比“闭合标签”高多了。
frequently than closing tag that just took over okay but yeah so so definitely give it a give it a check and uh um you know let me know what you think give me some feedback if you find bugs or typos let me know so okay yeah mine is a book that i wish i wrote does that count that counts you get royalties for that no i do not this is called the martian by andyir. Weir? I don't know. Andy. And this is basically, I think, I won't try to, I'll try not to spoil anything, but I think the back cover says it's basically Robinson Crusoe on Mars.
频繁得多，这个词已经完全取代了后者。好的，总之一定要去看看，如果发现任何错误或拼写错误，请务必告诉我，给我一些反馈。好的，我推荐的是一本我希望自己能写出来的书，这算数吗？算数，你能拿到版税吗？不，我拿不到。这本书叫《火星救援》，作者是安迪·威尔。威尔？我不知道，安迪。基本上，我想，我尽量不剧透，但封底介绍说这基本上就是火星版的《鲁滨逊漂流记》。
Oh, nice. But that's only like a vague, like, don't think too much about that, or you might have a mis-expectation about what the book is about so basically you know basically like a guy surviving where it's otherwise unexpected that he would survive um isn't that similar to the abyss the movie the abyss i've not watched that i don't know what that is oh basically in the abyss this guy um don't spoil it wait i might should i might should watch it read it no no i won't spoil it but basically you know he goes into the abyss this guy um don't spoil it wait i might should i might should watch it read it no no i won't spoil it but basically you know he goes into the abyss which is like a very deep trench and um he ends up there for a long time which you just wouldn't expect and so it sounds like it's kind of similar maybe so the guy on mars and what happens okay and so it's really cool
哦，不错。但这只是一个模糊的概念，别想太多，否则你可能会对这本书的内容产生错误的预期。基本上，你知道，就是一个在本来不可能幸存的情况下幸存下来的人。嗯，这和电影《深渊》不像吗？我没看过，不知道那是什么。哦，基本上在《深渊》里，这个人……别剧透，等等，我可能应该去看看或者读读。不，不，我不会剧透的，但基本上，你知道，他进入了深渊，这个人……别剧透，等等，我可能应该去看看或者读读。不，不，我不会剧透的，但基本上，你知道，他进入了深渊，那是一个非常深的海沟，他最终在那里待了很长时间，这是你完全没想到的。所以听起来可能有点相似，那个在火星上的人，以及发生的事情。好吧，这真的很酷。
has a lot of science in it but it's kind of one of those dangerous books where um there's a lot of science that makes sense to my head but i don't actually know if it's true because it's it's a fiction book oh right so like you ever you ever do that i don't know i read a lot of science fiction and then until like i have contradicting evidence i kind of just like have this bit of information in my head that i learned from a fictional book um yeah and oftentimes it turns out to be true right like somebody will write about something about black holes and it turns out that thing is actually true about black holes um except that there are no actual black holes anymore but um it'll turn
里面有很多科学知识，但这是一种危险的书，因为里面有很多科学知识在我的脑海里说得通，但我实际上不知道它们是否真实，因为这是一本虚构的书。哦，对，你有没有过这种经历？我不知道，我读了很多科幻小说，然后在我有反面证据之前，我脑子里就一直存着从虚构书籍中学到的这些信息。嗯，而且往往结果证明它们是真的，对吧？比如有人写了一些关于黑洞的东西，结果发现关于黑洞的那件事实际上是真的，除了现在已经没有真正的黑洞了，但它会……
out to be true like later on i'll find out but then other things i have no idea if they're true or not because i just read it in a fiction book but it sounds good to me yeah yeah this happens when you you read a fiction book and it starts off you know in the present or something there's a bunch of you know common landmarks everything seems pretty legit and then you know by the end of the book there's like aliens and orcs and dwarves are fighting each other and it's like well somewhere in between there it became fiction but you don't really know how where that gradient is yeah that's true like stuff will take place in like a city and it's like i know it's a valid city but i've never been there or and so i'll mention stuff that i know are like actual places there and then i just
结果证明是真的，后来我才发现。但其他事情我根本不知道它们是真是假，因为我只是在虚构书里读到的，但听起来对我来说很有道理。是的，是的，当你读一本虚构书时就会发生这种情况，它开始时是在现实中，或者类似的情况，有一堆常见的地标，一切看起来都很合理，然后到书的结尾，有外星人、兽人和矮人在互相打斗，你会觉得，好吧，在中间的某个地方它变成了虚构作品，但你真的不知道那个渐变点在哪里。是的，那是真的，比如事情发生在某个城市，我知道那是一个真实的城市，但我从来没去过那里，所以我提到的东西我知道是那里真实存在的地方，然后我就……
assume everything they mention is actually there. Right. And so, including the capital. Yes. Including the giant castle with heads on pikes. Yes. In Chicago. But anyways, I recommend this,
假设他们提到的所有东西实际上都在那里。对。包括首都。是的。包括那个插着人头的巨大城堡。是的。在芝加哥。但无论如何，我推荐这本书，《火星救援》。它不是很长。那是底特律。所以，那里，那里，它绝对是一本虚构书。因为你描述的那个地方在底特律。哦，
the Martian. It's not that long. That's a Detroit. So there were, there were, it's definitely a fiction book. Cause that what you described is in Detroit. Oh,
好吧。但安迪·威尔写的《火星救援》，我推荐它，读起来真的很有趣，而且它有点书呆子气。不管这种书呆子气是真实的还是编造的，作者要么花了很多时间做研究，要么他只是非常有创意。这太棒了，你知道，当你推荐《头号玩家》时，我立刻就读了，因为你的描述让我知道我一定会喜欢那本书，我确实喜欢，它太棒了。而且我一定会读这本书，你绝对应该读这本书，它不长，真的很好。而且它还有一些关于70年代电视节目的文化参考，我可能看不懂那些，但我还是会读这本书。
okay. But the Martian by Andyy weir i i recommend it was really fun read and um it was kind of nerdy whether or not the nerdiness was true or made up the guy either spent a lot of time doing research or he's just really creative this is great you know when you recommended ready player one i immediately read it because it just your description i just knew i was gonna love that book and i did it was great um and I definitely will read this book you should definitely read this book it's not that long it's really good um and it has also cultural references to like 70s tv shows uh I probably won't get any of those but I'll read the book
反正我也不懂，但我知道它们在那里。哦，好吧，有道理。所以除非那个70年代的电视节目是像《价格猜猜猜》之类的……嗯，是的，我现在不记得它们是什么了……但无论如何，是时候介绍本期工具了。好的，本期工具，工具，工具，我的本期工具。我不敢相信我们之前没谈过这个，但它是VirtualBox。VirtualBox太棒了。如果你还没用过，还没下载过，现在就去下载吧。我们现在的情况是，我在工作，我们有一台服务器。
anyway I didn't either but I knew that they were there oh okay fair enough uh so unless the 70s tv show is like uh price is right or something like that uh yeah i don't remember what they were now um but yeah something anyways uh time for tool of the show all right tool of the show show show my tool of the show i can't believe that we haven't talked about this before but uh it's virtual box and And VirtualBox is amazing. If you haven't used it, if you haven't downloaded it, just right now download it. We have this situation where I'm at work. We have this server.
我们服务器上没有编译器。所以我们弄清楚了它运行的是什么操作系统。然后使用VirtualBox，我们构建了……那是什么？使用VirtualBox，我们构建了一些源代码，我们将一些源代码编译成二进制文件，在这个虚拟PC中，然后把它发送过去。所以我简单解释一下VirtualBox。它有点像模拟器，就像那些任天堂之类的视频游戏模拟器。
And we don't have a compiler on the server. So we figured out what OS it was running. And then using VirtualBox, we built, what was that? Using VirtualBox we built some source code, we compiled some source code into binary in this virtual PC and then sent it over. So I'll explain VirtualBox briefly. It's kind of like an emulator, like those video game emulators for Nintendo and things like that.
但它模拟的是你自己的电脑。换句话说，它模拟了AMD 64或x86或任何架构，也就是你现在在台式机或笔记本电脑上运行的东西。它甚至可以挂载，如果你的BIOS足够新，它会做一些很酷的事情，让它运行得非常快，甚至可以使用你的显卡之类的。所以你可能正在运行Windows，你想尝试Linux，但又不想去买一台电脑，然后现在你的房子里放着两台电脑之类的。
But it emulates your own computer. So in other words, like it emulates, you know, an AMD 64 or x86 or whatever architecture, which is what you're running right now on your desktop or laptop and it even hooks in like if your bios is new enough it'll you know do some cool stuff there where it makes it really fast and it can even like use your graphics card and stuff like that so you know you might be running say windows you might want to try out Linux, but not have to go and buy a computer, and then now you have two computers sitting around your house or whatever.
所以你安装VirtualBox，然后在你的电脑里创建一个全新的电脑，即虚拟化电脑。它有自己的硬盘，在你的电脑上实际上只是一个文件，就像在所谓的宿主计算机上一样。但这个所谓的寄生计算机有它自己的硬盘、它自己的声卡，所有这些东西，但它们都是假的，但它们都能工作。你甚至可以像在主电脑上一样访问互联网，做任何事情。所以我用它做的一件事是，当我构建新版本的Maim Hub时，这是一个我参与的开源模拟器项目。在模拟器里构建模拟器，没错。所以我……那太硬核了，伙计。我需要……是的，我需要构建它。
So you install VirtualBox, and then you create a brand new computer inside of your computer, the virtualized computer. So it has its own hard drive, which on your computer is really just one file, like on what they call the host computer but then this sort of parasite computer it has its own hard drive it's only sound card all these things but they're all fake but they all work you can even like access the internet you can do everything you can do on your main computer so one thing that i use this for is when i'm building new versions of maim hub which is this this emulator that i'm emulator open source project that i work on when you build an emulator in an emulator that's right so i that's hardcore dude i need to yeah i need to build it
为Windows、Linux和Mac构建。甚至像我为Windows构建的版本，我想确保它能在原生Windows上运行。Mac也一样。我不希望它只在我的机器上能构建，因为我可能安装了各种疯狂的库和一些荒谬的设置之类的。你知道，我把它复制到别人的Mac上，它就不能用了。所以我为每个操作系统都有一个VirtualBox客户机。然后我启动所有这些。我实际上可以同时启动它们所有。现在我坐在这里，每个可能的操作系统都有一个窗口。
for windows linux and mac um and even like the one i build for Windows, I want to make sure it runs on just native Windows. And same for Mac. Like I don't want to just, if it builds on my machine, I might have all sorts of crazy libraries and some ridiculous setup or whatever. You know, I copy it over to someone else's Mac, it doesn't work. So I have a virtual box guest machine for every OS. And then I launch all of those. I can actually launch all of them at the same time. And now I'm sitting and I have a window for every possible OS.
在每一个窗口里，我都有代码，我可以更新、构建，然后部署。所以这很酷。我的意思是，还有，假设你想在普通的Windows或普通的Mac上测试东西，或者其他什么。所以这很酷。我的意思是，还有，假设你想在普通的Windows或普通的Mac上测试东西，或者其他什么。你想确保这个网站或者你构建的任何东西在朋友的电脑上仍然能运行。
And in each of those, I have, you know, the code, which I can update, build, and then deploy. So it's pretty cool. I mean, also, you know, let's say you want to test things, you know, on just regular Windows or regular Mac or what have you. So it's pretty cool. I mean, also, let's say you want to test things on just regular Windows or regular Mac or what have you. And you want to make sure that this website or whatever you built still works on your friend's computer.
但你可以只用一台虚拟电脑，上面什么都没有。它是完全空白的。在那台电脑上访问你的网站，看看会发生什么。所以这太神奇了。那叫什么？当指令在你的CPU上运行，但其他一切都被虚拟化时，我有一个特定的名字，但我忘了它叫什么了。是的，就像VT-x之类的，那是BIOS设置，我不知道。嗯，是的，但你是对的，有一个术语，因为有模拟超级任天堂，它有不同的处理器，然后有允许指令实际运行，但有足够的钩子，这样每当它调用系统调用时，你就会捕获它并将其切换为其他东西。是的，对，是的。嗯，该死，那叫什么？没关系，这在我说话的时候一直困扰着我。是的，它是……有重新编译，这是第一种情况。所以重新编译是，你知道，有为超级任天堂编译的代码，你重新编译它，你把它们的机器码变成你的机器码。但另一种情况是，它已经是你的机器码了，你只需要捕获某些指令。我也忘了那叫什么了。无论如何，VirtualBox就是这样做的。它不像QEMU或其他那些。
But you could just have a virtual computer, which doesn't have anything on it. It's just completely bare. And go to your website on that computer and see what happens. So it's pretty amazing. What is that's called something i have a specific name for when the instructions run on the cpu you're on but everything else is virtualized but i forgot what it's called yeah it's like vtx or something like that that's like the bio setting i don't know um yeah but you're right there is a term for it because there's like emulating a super nintendo which has a different
运行起来非常痛苦。所以如果你使用Android模拟器……实际上它现在快多了，因为他们做了我们描述的事情，但最初版本的Android模拟器实际上将你所有的指令从ARM重新编译成了x86，这非常慢。但是的，VirtualBox，它很快，它做你想做的一切，它处理图形。它比VMware或Parallels之类的更好用吗？它是免费的，而且它做我想要的一切，所以我从来没试过其他的。但好吧，嗯，是的，我的意思是，过去VMware可以做一些VirtualBox做不到的事情。我知道现在它们基本持平了。VirtualBox，我想Direct 3D。
processor and then there's like allowing the instructions to actually run but having just enough hooks so anytime it calls a system call you you trap it and you switch it out for something else yeah right yeah um crap what is that called it's okay it's been bothering me the whole time you've been talking yeah it's um there's recompilation which is that's the first case so recompilation is where you know there's code that's been compiled for like the super nintendo and you um recompile it you turn their machine code into your machine code but then the other one where it's it's already your machine code you just need to catch certain instructions i forgot what that's called too anyways virtual blocks does that it's not like qemc or one of these other ones
支持仍然是实验性的，这归结为你必须勾选一个框，表示你想要使用这个实验性功能。但是的，我还没发现有什么是我在VirtualBox里做不到的。好吧，很好。是的，好时光。
which run like painfully so like if you use the android emulator um actually it's a lot faster now because they do what we're describing but the original version of the android emulator actually recompiled um all of your instructions from um arm into uh into x86 which is brutally slow um but yeah virtualbox it's fast it does everything you want it handles graphics does it work better than like what is the other one like vmware or parallels or so it's free and uh it does everything i want so i've never tried any of the other ones but okay um yeah i mean it used to be that vmware could do some things that virtual box couldn't. I know now they're pretty much even. VirtualBox, I think the direct 3D
我本周的工具是BitTorrent Sync。所以人们对BitTorrent有问题，它是一个协议，也是一家公司之类的，对吧？我想。无论如何，BitTorrent公司制作了这个同步产品，它的基本前提与常规BitTorrent相同，但不是从BitTorrent用户云中下载Linux的最新版本文件（这应该是你唯一应该用它做的事情），你基本上可以对自己做这件事。所以这是一个用BitTorrent技术实现的Dropbox，这是一个简单的说法。哦，我明白了。所以如果我妈妈运行这个，我也运行这个，我们可以共享我们的照片。所以如果我们的房子烧毁了……没错。而且它不依赖。
support is still experimental, which just comes down to you have to check a box saying that you want to do this experimental feature. But yeah, I've yet to find something I couldn't do in VirtualBox. Alright, well, very good. Yeah, it's good times.
中央服务器，所以它完全是分布式的。而且它很容易设置。我不能保证它的安全性，我不会用它做任何敏感或安全的事情。但我确实有一台电脑，我的房子有两层，实际上我有三层……在我家，在人们兴奋起来之前。无论如何，我的车库里实际上有一台电脑，因为我在那里工作时会用到它，还有一台电脑在我的顶楼，也就是我的办公室。我想在它们之间同步，而不需要USB驱动器，所以我用这个，因为有些文件我想在它们之间来回共享。所以我可以在两台电脑上运行它，然后目录保持同步，我不用担心大小限制，我可以运行多个不同的目录，也不用担心账户问题。而且……
My tool of the week is bit torrent sync uh so people have issue with the bit torrent which is like a protocol but also a company or whatever right i think anyway so the company bit torrent made this sync product and it works on the same basic premise as regular BitTorrent but instead of downloading from the cloud of BitTorrent users a file of the newest version of Linux only that's the only thing you should use it for you can basically do that with yourself so it's Dropbox implemented with the bit torrent technology is an easy way to say it oh i see so if like my mom has like uh this running and i have it running like we can share our pictures so if one of our houses burned down that's right and it doesn't it doesn't rely
你实际设置它的方式非常简单。有一个东西他们称之为“密钥”，是一个……我忘了有多长，一个64字符的字符串哈希，基本上。当你创建一个共享文件夹时，它会给你一个哈希值，然后你可以在其他电脑上共享那个哈希值。我只是把它发邮件给自己，然后你可以把它共享到其他电脑，把哈希值放进去，然后它就会开始同步到那个文件夹。任何其他人如果输入它，即使是陌生人，也会开始共享到那个文件夹。哦，我明白了。但有那么多可能的数字。是的，所以我认为发生这种情况的几率非常低。通过匿名性实现安全，或者类似匿名性的东西。是的，它也会向你显示有人在同步时，以及其他公司……所以你会知道，如果你在观察，我想当它发生时，或者查看日志，你就能看到，哦，其他人不小心和我碰撞了。但我认为。
on central servers so it's just all distributed um and it's easy to set up i wouldn't i i can't vouch for the security of it i don't use it for anything that's sensitive or secure or any of that but i do have like a computer i have two stories in my house i actually have three stories um in my house my townhome before people get all excited anyways uh it's so like my garage i actually have a computer in my garage because i use it when i'm working down there and a computer in my top top up where my my office is and i want to synchronize between them without a usb drive and so i use this because there's files i want to be shared back and forth between them and so i can run it on both computers and then the directories are kept in sync and i don't have to worry about size limits i can have multiple different ones running and i don't have to worry about accounts and the way
它可能足够长，在统计学上不太可能发生，除非有人在狩猎，然后使用大量电脑来寻找活跃的哈希值之类的。你知道，这总是让我着迷，就像那种有一亿分之一或万亿分之一的几率，我得到了一些非常重要的文件……我觉得这是一本等待被写的书，你知道，某种惊悚片，你输错了你的BitTorrent Sync密钥，突然你得到了真正的NSA机密之类的。但这就像《皇后区之王》的一集，我想曾经有过。这确实很有趣，就像他们去……是他们吗？不，我试图记住是那个还是另一个节目，某个节目。
you actually set it up is really easy there's this thing they call a secret which is a i forget how long like a 64 character uh string hash basically and when you create a share folder it gives you a hash and then you can share that hash on other computers i just email it to myself uh and then you can share it to other computers put the hash in there and then it'll start synchronizing to that and anyone else who puts it in even a stranger would also start sharing to that folder oh i see but there's so many possible numbers yeah so i think the chance of that happening is really low security by anonymity or something like anonymity yeah and it also does show you like when someone's sinking and what other companies so you would know if like if you were watching i guess when it was happening or look in the logs you'd be able to see like oh someone else accidentally collided with me but i think
我忘了，他们去冲洗胶卷，他们取回了照片，他们不小心拿到了别人的照片，然后他们基本上开始通过那些人的生活进行代入式生活。就像他们一直这样做，他们想一直找出这些人是谁，为什么他们比自己好得多，或者其他什么，更有趣，做着很酷的事情。哦，天哪，那太棒了。所以，好吧，好时光。好吧，是时候讨论本期主题了：设计模式。设计模式。所以，是的，基本上，在高层面上，设计模式是这些社区公认的、你知道的、编程时的好策略。通常，虽然其中一些对某些类型的语言或某些范式有点具体。
it's probably long enough where statistically is very unlikely to happen uh unless someone was hunting and then using a lot of computers to hunt for uh active hashes or whatever you know this always fascinates me like the idea that there's a one in a you know whatever a billion or a trillion chance that i get like all of you know some like really important documents like i feel like this is a book waiting to happen you know like some kind of thriller where it's like you you mistype your your bit torrent sync secret and all of a sudden you get real nsa secrets or something but this was like a king of queens episode i think once it is it is intriguing where it's like they go to the is it them no what i'm trying to remember if it's that or another show some show
但通常它们适用于几乎任何语言和几乎任何你正在处理的任务。是的，我认为设计模式，当我第一次接触时，人们总是说，哦，它们太革命性了。我不知道。当他们第一次了解它们时，这是一个很大的事情。但我没有那种经历。对我来说，它只是像你如果编程有一段时间了。
i i forget and they go to the get film developed and they uh pick up their pictures and they accidentally pick up someone else's pictures and then they start living vicariously through those people's lives basically like they keep doing it and they want to keep finding out who these people are and why they're so much better or whatever and more interesting and doing cool things oh man that's awesome so all right good times well time for the topic of the show design patterns design patterns so yeah basically um at a high level design patterns are sort of these like communal agreed upon you know good strategies when you're programming and generally um although some of them are a little bit specific to certain types of languages or certain paradigms,
或者看过别人的代码，你可能至少见过大部分想法。但这只是让它具体化的一种方式，比如通过理解它并给它起一个名字——一个模式，你就会认出它。通过认出它，你就可以重用代码，因为你已经知道怎么做了，或者你可以不掉进那些你知道用那个模式很可能会发生的陷阱里，而不是像编程的狂野西部那样，你只是随心所欲地编码，每次需要做某事时都重新发明轮子。
but generally they apply to almost any language and almost any task that you're working on. Yeah, I think design patterns, when I first got introduced, people were always like, oh, they're so revolutionary. I don't know. It was such a big deal when they first learned about them. And I didn't have that same experience. What it is to me is just kind of like things you, if you've been programming for any length of time
所以这只是将这些想法编纂成册并给它们起名字，为人们交流提供一种通用语言的一种方式。是的，我的意思是，通用语言真的很重要。我的意思是，你知道，这在编程竞赛中也是如此。所以我大学时参加了很多编程竞赛，写题目的人通常是前参赛者，对吧？所以你最终会得到这种……这种通过多年积累起来的通用语言。而且教练也是题目编写者，也是前参赛者，它只是自我循环。你必须……如果你。
or seen other people's code, you've probably seen at least most of the ideas. But it's just a way of making it concrete and like saying by understanding it and giving it a name a pattern you'll recognize it and by recognizing it you won't you can reuse code because you already know how to do it or you can not fall into the traps that you know are likely to happen with that pattern versus just you know kind of the wild west of coding where you just code whatever you want and reinvent it
如果你不是那种圈子里的人，那么你知道，你可能很聪明，但你不会朝着同一个方向聪明，你所知道的和你所知道的评委或题目编写者所知道的之间不会有足够的重叠，你就不会做得很好。所以这是编程中的这些事情之一，你知道，通过学习这些做事方式并知道何时发现它们，它会让你更容易融入生态系统。是的，它们不是灵丹妙药。很多人认为，哦，我只要用一个设计模式，它就能解决我的问题。也许吧，可能不会。我们不会尝试涵盖所有这些，因为我们只能做……没有足够好的帮助。
every time you need to do something um right and so it's just a way of codifying these ideas and giving them names in a common language for people to talk about. Yeah, I mean, the common language is really important. I mean, there's, you know, it's sort of like this is true with programming contests. So I did a lot of programming contests back in college and the people who write the questions are usually ex-competitors right and so you end up with this with this like gnosis this common language that's built up through the years and like the the coaches are also problem writers are also former contestants and and it just kind of feeds on itself and you have to sort of if
关于它的事情，所以我们只尝试涵盖几个，也许以后我们会有设计模式2。是的，如果你喜欢这一集，那么你知道，去看看维基百科关于设计模式的页面，因为那里有成吨的模式。但我们主要会涵盖我们有实际经验和故事可以分享的那些。是的，而且……你知道，其中一些，特别是我们一会儿要谈的第一个，我见过人们过度使用它，就像它流行起来了，很时髦，然后我看到人们用它来为糟糕的行为辩护。他们做了一些坏事。
you're not sort of in the click then you know you could be brilliant but you won't be brilliant in the same direction and there won't be enough overlap in what you know and what you know the the judges or the the problem writers know and you just won't do well and so this is one of these things with programming where you know by learning these ways of doing them and knowing where to when to spot them it will sort of like make it easier for you to integrate yourself in the ecosystem yep um they're not magic bullets a lot of people think like oh i'll just use a design pattern and it'll fix my problem maybe i don't probably not um we won't try to cover all of them because we would only be able to do a uh not enough good helpful
他们做了这件事作为替代。然后因为这是一个设计模式，他们说，哦，但这是一个设计模式。就像是，是的，但你仍然在做坏事。你只是给它贴了个标签。所以带着这个过渡，我们来谈谈单例模式。单例模式的想法是，我想，就像它听起来的那样。你想要一个单一的东西，只有一个单例……我想就像它听起来的那样，你想要一个单一的东西，只有一个东西。所以一个类的一个实例，无论人们是否尝试创建新实例，他们都应该得到同一个实例。所以人们只是得到了某种相同的引用。
things about it so we're going to try to cover only a few and maybe we'll have a design patterns too later yeah if you like this episode then you know go and check out the wikipedia page on design patterns because there's there's a ton of them but we're mainly going to cover ones that we have you know practical experience and stories to share and things like that yeah and um you know some of them especially we'll talk about the first one a second i've seen people overuse like it was like it caught on and it was fashionable and then i saw people use it in you know a way to excuse bad behavior almost. They were doing something bad.
对同一个对象的引用。所以，这有很多有用的应用。正如我所暗示的，近年来它似乎也得到了很多糟糕的使用。所以它非常擅长的一件事是，如果你有一个类，并且你想在应用程序的所有部分之间共享数据。例如，如果你有一个日志文件处理程序，并且你想能够从你的错误处理系统写入该日志，但你的错误处理系统从各个地方获取错误，或者其他什么，你可能有不同的错误处理实例，但它们都想出于某种原因追加到同一个日志中。你可以有一个代表日志的单例对象，任何要求“嘿，我想要一个日志实例”的人。
They did this thing instead. And then because it's a design pattern, they're like, oh, but it's a design pattern. And it's like, yeah, but you're still doing the bad thing. You just labeled it. So with that transition, we'll talk about the singleton. So the idea of a singleton is, I guess, kind of what it sounds like. You want a single something, only one of a singleton is i guess kind of what it sounds like you want a single something only one of a thing um so one instance of a class and no matter if people try to create new instances they should just get back the same instance so people are just getting kind of the same reference
都会得到同一个共享实例，只有一个文件，但每个人都可以把信息传进去。这并不意味着它自动是多线程安全的。所以这是一个单独的话题，但每个人至少会知道要写入哪个文件，然后可以单独处理。
reference to the same object and so um this has a lot of useful applications. And as I was alluding to, in recent years seems to have gotten a lot of bad uses as well. So one thing that it's really great at is if you have a class and you want to share data amongst all parts of your applications. So for instance, if you had a file handler for a log log and you wanted to be able to write to that log from you know your error handling system but your error handling system gets errors from all over the place or whatever and you may have different instances of error handling but they all want to append to the same log for whatever reason you could have a singleton object that represented the log and anybody who asked for x hey, I want an instance of the log
如何以安全的方式写入它。但这是你可能想在整个应用程序中共享并传递的东西。所以……是的。请继续。哦，是的。单例模式的好处还在于。
would get the same shared instance, just one file, but everybody could pass information into it. That doesn't mean it's automatically multi-thread safe. So that's a separate topic, but everybody would at least know what file was going to be written to and then could kind of handle separately
如果你在某个地方有一些全局变量，这可能是它的替代方案，那么你永远不知道它们何时被初始化。但单例模式的特点是，你知道，通过设计，当你调用“获取实例”或“获取单例”或任何你想调用的函数来获取你的单例时，它可以检查并查看单例是否已初始化。然后根据你的逻辑设置方式。
how to write to it in a safe fashion. But that's something you might want to share throughout an application and pass around. And so... Yeah. Go ahead. Oh, yeah. The nice thing about a singleton too is
如果你尝试过早使用它，你可以报错，或者你可以即时初始化它。但与仅仅坐在那里的某个变量、某个数字相比，这会让你知道单例处于什么状态。因为编写应用程序时最困难的事情之一往往是让一个非常复杂的应用程序。
if you have just global variables sitting around somewhere, which would be sort of alternative to this, then you never really know when they're initialized or not. But the thing about a singleton is that, you know, by design, when you say, you know, get instance or get singleton or whatever function that you want to call to get your singleton, it can check and see if the singleton's initialized. And then depending on how your logic is set up,
正确启动，顺序正确，这样就不会出问题。是的，所以有些人确实使用它，比如你提到的那种延迟初始化，所以它直到有人真正需要它时才被初始化。这可能很好，比如避免在初始应用程序时……不同的语言和模型有不同的阶段。所以泛泛地说，直到有人真正去使用那个单例的东西，它才会运行执行初始化的那部分代码。所以在那之前，它只是坐在那里，不初始化它的所有变量和状态。所以如果它需要做一些昂贵的事情，这会非常有帮助。但是做。
you can either error if you tried to use it too early or you can initialize it on the fly. But as opposed to just some variable, some number that's sitting out there, this will sort of let you know at what state the singleton is in. Because often one of the hardest things to do in writing an app is you get a very complicated app
在未来某个未知的时间做昂贵的事情也可能是危险的。对。没错。所以那不好。然后杰森提到了全局变量，这是我见过人们使用的一种东西。所以很多人开始明白全局变量是危险的，因为很难跟踪谁在改变什么，所以你的代码的很多部分可能会改变一个全局变量，然后如果它进入了糟糕的状态，很难分辨是谁改变了它，除此之外还有其他问题。所以我见过人们……单例模式的糟糕用法之一是基本上拥有这些从各处修改的全局变量，只是把它们塞进一个单例里，而不是让它们作为全局变量。
to start correctly and in the right order so that nothing blows up yeah so some people do use it so like you mentioned kind of lazy initialization so it's not initialized until someone actually needs it and that can be good that like avoiding code at you know when the initial app with it different languages and models have different stages so speaking generically it's not until someone actually goes to use the thing that's a singleton that it actually runs the part of the code that does the initialization so before that it just kind of sits there and doesn't initialize all its variables and its state and so that can be really helpful if it needs to do something expensive. But doing
我不认为你让问题变得好多了。对。你让共享全局变量变得更容易了，但你并没有降低伤害自己的可能性。是的，完全正确。完全正确。酷。是的，我的意思是，你绝对会随处可见单例模式。
something expensive at an unknown time in the future can also be dangerous. Right. Exactly. So that's not good. And then Jason mentioned global variables, which is one of the things I've seen people. So a lot of people have begun to understand that global variables are dangerous because it's a way of it's very difficult to keep track of who's changing what and so a lot of pieces of your code may change something that's a global variable and then if it gets into a bad state it's hard to tell who changed it amongst other problems and so i've seen people one of the bad uses of the singleton is to basically have these global variables that are modified from everywhere and just stick them in a singleton instead of leaving them as global variables.
你真的无法避免它，因为几乎总是，无论是某种硬件组件，还是像帕特里克说的，某种日志记录，所以它绑定到你电脑上的单个文件。几乎总是有你代码的某一部分，你知道，绑定到数据库或其他什么，你知道，必须只有一个副本被许多不同的客户端共享。所以……单例模式是一种让它工作的简单方法。对。是的，而且单例模式确实也被用在许多其他设计模式中，因为它们想要某种东西只有一个……对，这就是你实现它的方式。
And I don't think you've made the problem much better. Right. You've made it easier to share around the global variables, but you haven't made it less likely that you'll hurt yourself. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Cool. Yeah, I mean, definitely you'll see singletons everywhere you go.
所以设计模式可以被用在其他设计模式中。震惊。递归设计模式。是的。所以我真的很喜欢的一个是外观模式。所以，你知道，想象一下，对吧？你正在编写某个应用程序，你想为你的应用程序拥有某种数据库。所以你可以做某种像HBase或Cassandra的东西。
You really can't avoid it because there's almost always, like whether it's some kind of hardware component or, as Patrick said, some kind of logging, so it's tied to a single file on your computer. There's almost always some part of your code which is you know is tied to either you know database what have you which you know there has to be only one copy of that shared by many different clients and so um the singleton is an easy way to sort of get that to work right yeah and and the singleton does get used in a lot of the other design patterns as well because they want only one of something um right and that's how you kind of do it.
实际上，我们稍后会有一个关于数据库的节目。但现在，只把这个当作表面价值。你可以使用这些非常分布式、容错、所有这些非常健壮的数据库之一。但设置起来非常痛苦，而且有点像噩梦。如果你不知道自己在做什么，特别是如果你做了很多初始化和所有这些东西。现实情况是你可能不需要那个。比如你的网站或你的应用程序或任何东西。
So design patterns can be used in other design patterns. Shocker. Recursive design patterns. Yeah. So one that I really like is facade. So, you know, imagine this, right? You're writing some app and you want to have some kind of database for your app. So you could do some kind of like HBase or Cassandra.
它可能不需要那种大锤。你可能只需要把所有东西存储在电脑上的一个文件里就够了，对吧？所以每当你遇到这种情况，你就会陷入困境，有几个选择，对吧？你可以说，好吧，为了应对增长，我要使用HBase或这些东西之一，然后花几天时间设置和维护它之类的。你可以走另一个极端，说我只是要把所有东西都放在一个单一的文本文件里，我所有的数据，我所有的用户数据，所有东西都在一个文本文件里，当我启动服务器时，我会把它们全部加载到内存中。然后会发生什么，那会让你应付过去。
And actually, we're going to have a show on databases later. But for now, just take this at face value. You could use one of these really distributed, fault-tolerant, all these very robust databases. But it's a huge pain to set up and it's kind of a nightmare. If you don't know what you're doing, especially if you do a lot of initialization and all this stuff. And the reality is you might not need that. Like your website or your app or whatever,
但突然之间，你的应用程序上了Slashdot或Hacker News的头版之类的。突然之间，你的网站完全崩溃了，你将需要几个月的时间来重写你的整个网站，以便你可以使用HBase或这些东西之一。现在你真的陷入了困境。所以你可以做的另一件事，你必须做出这种决定，有很多很多次你必须为你的应用程序的各个部分做出这样的决定，就是创建一个外观。
it might not need that kind of a sledgehammer. You might be fine with just storing everything on a file on your computer, right? So whenever you have this kind of situation, you're stuck with, there are several options, right? You could either say, well, to account for growth,'m gonna you know you know use hbase or one of these things and you know spend days setting it up and maintaining it things like that you can go the other end and say i'm just gonna put everything in a single just text file all my data all my user data everything will be in a text file and i'll load it all into memory when i start up the server and then what will happen is that will get you by,
所以创建一个库，在这种情况下，考虑数据库，创建一个库，你可以用某种格式给它数据，然后它会有几种后端。所以可能是任何时候你写任何东西，任何时候你的应用程序必须写任何需要留存的东西，需要去磁盘或类似的东西，它通过你的库，然后到硬盘。
but then all of a sudden your app makes it on Slashdot or the front page of Hacker News or something like that. And all of a sudden your website completely blows up and it's going to take you months to rewrite your whole website so that you can use HBase or one of these things. And now you're really in a struggle. So another thing you can do, and you have to make these kind of decisions, there's many, many times you have to make decisions like this for various parts of your app, is to create a facade.
所以打开文件并读取它的东西之间有一些东西。在你和你的代码之间有一些东西，需要获取和存储数据。然后如果你的应用程序变得非常成功，那个中间层可以调用一个不同的……你知道，一个不同的数据库。而不是从文件读取，它可以从MongoDB或Cassandra或类似的东西读取，而不需要改变它上面的所有东西。所以。
So create some library where, in this case, think about in terms of a database, create some library where you can give it data in some format, and then it will have sort of several back ends. So it might be that any time you write anything, any time your app has to write anything that needs to stick around, that needs to go to disk or something like that, it goes through your library and then to the hard drive.
这是一个外观的例子。所以我几年前写了一个开源库，我今天仍然在使用它，叫Zombie DB，它实际上只是这些数据库的一堆外观。所以当时我真的不知道我想用哪个数据库，我不想做一堆编码，结果发现我必须全部重做。所以我创建了这个外观。通常当你拥有这些东西时，因为有像数据库或某种……你拥有这些东西，因为有像数据库或某种……网络或任何像库的东西，你没有源代码……你知道，或者任何真正复杂的东西，你可能有源代码，但你……
So there's something in between the thing that opens the file and reads it. There's something in between that and your code, which needs to get and store data. Then if your app becomes really successful, that middle layer can just call a different know, a different database. Instead of like reading from the file, it can read from MongoDB or Cassandra or something like that without having to change all of the stuff above it. So
永远不想看它，你知道，像Hadoop之类的，就像你只是……你知道，交叉手指希望它能工作。任何像那样你有选择，而且你不确定选择哪个选项的东西，外观模式会让你一次选择所有选项。还有什么比这更好的呢？一次选择所有选项，是的。总是正确的选择。是的，没错。当一切都失败时，选择一切。
this is an example of a facade. So there's one open source library I wrote a few years ago that I still use today called zombie DB and it's literally just a facade for a bunch of these databases so at the time I didn't really know which database I wanted to use and I didn't want to do a bunch of coding only to find out that I have to redo it all so I created this facade and generally when you have these kind of things because there's like databases or some kind of like you have these kind of things because there's like databases or some kind of like networking or any kind of like library where you don't have the source code um you know or anything kind of really complicated that you might have the source code but you'd
当然，缺点是，将你的外观连接到每一个后端仍然是你的责任，这最终可能会非常耗时。同样，你可以以懒惰的方式做到这一点。你的外观可以只连接到一个后端，然后稍后。
never want to look at it you know like hadoop or something like that where it's like you just you know cross your fingers and hope it works anything like that where where you have options and you're not sure which option to choose, a facade will let you choose all of the options at once. And what could be better than that? Choosing all the options at once, yes. Always the right option. Yeah, that's right. When all else fails, choose everything.
如果你需要第二个，或者你想探索第二个，你可以这样做。不错。这一集要谈的第三个是观察者或发布者订阅者设计模式。嗯，这个……在某种程度上有点显而易见，我想。但我认为很多人错过了可以使用它的机会，因为他们觉得它太昂贵了，因为它听起来很像消息传递或排队，这可能会变得昂贵，但它不必如此。它所说的只是，你知道，你有一些东西想要观察另一个类中发生的事情，你需要一种方法来注册它，然后让它得到通知。
Of course, on the downside, the onus is still on you to connect your facade to each of those backends, and that could end up being pretty time-consuming. Again, you can do that in a lazy fashion. Your facade could just connect to one backend, and then later on
当那件事发生时。所以实际保持哪些东西需要被通知可以只是，你知道，像链表或数组一样简单，或者，你知道，它不必像真正的队列或消息传递那样复杂。这对于如果你有系统的不同部分，你……创建事件，不知道谁必然……你不想硬编码，比如，嘿，我正在尝试想一个好的例子。所以我的设备，所以我有一个设备驱动程序，对吧？在某个时候我有……哦，开始了。我有机器人，我有一个激光扫描仪。
if you need a second one or you want to explore a second one, you can do that. Nice. The third one to talk about this episode is the observer or publisher subscriber design pattern um and this one it's kind of obvious i guess at some level but you know i think a lot of people miss opportunities where you could use it because they feel like it's too expensive because it sounds a lot like message passing or queuing things which can get expensive but it doesn't have to be all it says is you know you have something that wants to observe something happen in another class and there you need a way to register that and then for it to get notified
所以在某个时候，这可能会随时间改变，我对房间的扫描完成了。我有一张房间的图像，我的激光测距仪发现的一堆距离。而且它完成了。但目前可能没有人……机器人可能处于某种不移动阶段，或者不在乎阶段，或者仍在处理上一个。
when that thing has happened so the actual keeping what things need to be notified can just be you know as simple as a linked list or an array or you know it doesn't have to be complicated like actually like a full-blown queue or message passing and this is really useful for if you have different parts of your system that you, kind of create events and don't know who necessarily, you don't want a hard code that like, hey, my, I'm trying to think of a good example. So my device, so I have a device driver, right? And at some point I have, oh, here we go. I have robot and I have a laser scanner.
所以此时可能没有人关心，嘿，我完成了扫描房间，这是我的数据。作为编写该设备的驱动程序，我真的不应该关心。哇，那太多的关心了。我不应该担心是否有人关心我的数据。我只是完成了数据的制作。然后，你知道，我有点委托给这部分代码，它去说，嘿，谁目前需要被通知？任何需要被通知的人，我通知他们，然后他们可以采取适当的行动。所以这就是……那种设计模式的基础。
So at some point, which can change over time, my scanning of the room is complete. And I have a image of the room, a bunch of distances that my laser range finder has found. And it's complete. But nobody may currently, the robot may be in like a not moving stage or not care stage or still processing the last one.
它在很多地方都很有用，因为那个概念，就像我说的，当我编写我的代码部分时，我不必担心，我不一定担心谁在听，或者必须有一个硬编码的列表，这里是需要通知的，它需要改变，它需要被维护。然后当我添加一些新的需要被通知的东西时，我必须去100个不同的地方添加它。是的，我的意思是，这节省了……是的，完全正确。这节省了一个巨大的头痛。
So nobody may care at this time that, hey, I finished scanning the room, here's my data. And as writing the device driver for that, I really shouldn't have to care. Wow, that's too many cares. I shouldn't have to worry about if anyone cares about my data or not. I simply just finish making the data. And then, you know, I kind of delegate to this piece of code that goes and says, hey, who currently needs to be notified? And anyone who needs to be notified, I notify notify them and then they can take appropriate action and so that's the the kind of the basis of
我的意思是，我过去不知道这个，就像我刚开始的时候，它最终变成了一个噩梦。就像，例如，因为有所有这些级联效应，对吧？就像……你知道，我正在制作这个视频游戏，就像，好吧，所以我推了这个角色，它就像这些战术游戏之一，它有点像国际象棋，但你知道，可以移动的棋子。就像，好吧，我推了这个棋子……现在棋子被推到了一个他不在坚实地面上的地方，就像他在漂浮，我把他推下了山之类的。所以他必须掉下去，但我需要展示掉下去的动画，然后每一回合他们都需要……
that that design pattern and it is useful in a lot of places because that notion like i said i don't have to worry about when i'm writing my piece of the code i don't necessarily worry about who else is listening or having to have a hard-coded list of here's to notify that needs to change and it needs to be maintained. And then when I add something new that needs to be notified, I got to go add it to 100 different places. Yeah, I mean, this saves, yeah, exactly. This saves like a gigantic headache.
那种设计模式在很多地方都很有用，因为正如我所说，我不需要担心在编写代码时谁在监听，也不需要硬编码一个需要通知的列表，还得去维护它。如果我添加了新的需要通知的对象，我就得去一百个不同的地方修改。是的，这确实省去了巨大的麻烦。
I mean, I used to not know about this, like when I started and it ended up with a nightmare it's like for example there's because there's all these cascading effects right it's like uh you know I was making this video game and it was like okay so I pushed this person it was like one of these like tactical games like it was kind of like chess but you know pieces that can move around it's like okay I pushed this piece um and now the piece got pushed to a place where he's not on solid ground like he's like floating i pushed off a mountain or something so he has to fall but then i need to like show an animation of the falling and then every turn they need to
我以前不知道这个，刚开始的时候简直是一场噩梦。比如，因为存在各种连锁反应，我当时在做一个电子游戏，类似于那种战棋游戏，有点像国际象棋，棋子可以移动。当我推动一个棋子时，它被推到了一个不是实地的地方，比如悬空了，或者从山上掉下来了，所以我必须展示坠落的动画，而且每一回合它们都需要...
fall a little further there's just like all of these you know nested effects and then eventually what would happen is invariably you know they would fall and somehow that would cause the first player to get experience so i tried to add to the experience but i was already in the context of the first player so it caused some kind of deadlock and the whole game would crash and i realized that you know trying to handle all of the side effects of of your code just by calling the appropriate function just leads to a complete mess. This is a complete nightmare. I mean, if you find yourself, you know, 15 levels deep in function calls, that's a bad sign.
再往下掉一点，就会出现各种嵌套效应，最终不可避免地会发生这种情况：他们掉下去了，不知怎么地导致第一个玩家获得了经验值。所以我尝试增加经验值，但我已经在第一个玩家的上下文中了，这导致了某种死锁，整个游戏都会崩溃。我意识到，仅仅通过调用适当的函数来处理代码的所有副作用，只会导致一团糟。这简直是一场噩梦。我的意思是，如果你发现自己陷入了 15 层深的函数调用中，那是一个不好的信号。
So this pub subscribe lets you say, look, you know, it doesn't have to happen right away. And most of the time that's true. So just say, this guy got pushed off a mountain, so the next time I have a chance, he needs to get hurt and fall off the mountain or something like that. But it doesn't have to happen right now. So the idea of sort of separating the time that you're presenting to the user,
所以这种发布-订阅模式让你能够说，看，它不一定非要马上发生。大多数情况下确实如此。所以只要说，这家伙被推下了山，那么下次我有机会的时候，他需要受伤并掉下山之类的。但这不一定非要现在发生。所以这种将你呈现给用户的时间与代码实际流程分离开来的想法，
and this is true whether you're doing a game or an email system or what have you, right? Like separating, you know, the time that, you know, the text upon which you present things to the user from the actual flow of your code is really important. And just knowing that you can make several passes through your code before you show, you know, output to the user gives you a lot more freedom.
无论你是在做游戏、电子邮件系统还是其他什么，这都是正确的。比如，将你向用户呈现事物的时间与代码的实际流程分离开来非常重要。而且只要知道你可以在向用户展示输出之前对代码进行多次处理，就能给你带来更多的自由。
And there are some dangers, right? So like I said, if I'm going to notify a bunch of people that my laser scan of the room is complete, that probably requires a lot of processing to handle. And I might call several people who are, several people, wow, several other classes that are interested in that, that may want to do heavy processing, right? And without care, I could synchronously be doing that every five seconds to do heavy processing right and without care i could synchronously be doing that every five seconds when i finish right so it's relatively slow every once every five seconds and then it needs to do a lot of processing and that could delay the system
当然也存在一些危险。就像我说的，如果我要通知一群人我的房间激光扫描已经完成，那可能需要大量的处理工作。我可能会调用几个感兴趣的类，它们可能想要进行繁重的处理。如果不小心，我可能会每五秒钟同步执行一次繁重的处理，这会拖慢系统。
but the things you notify don't have to process right away it could simply be that they need to know that next time that they get their time slice to process that they have something that they have to handle like oh hey this thing now has data and it lives at this address so you should go read it right um and that that's something that you have to to take into account as well yeah i mean the downside of the pub subscribe is exactly the same as the upside which is it know, things don't happen immediately. So, I mean, they happen whenever the subscriber, you know, reads the next message. And so if as a publisher, you know, you publish some data and then you immediately expect, you know, you make assumptions about that.
但你通知的事物不一定非要马上处理。它们可能只是需要知道，下次它们获得处理时间片时，有需要处理的事情，比如“嘿，这个东西现在有数据了，它存放在这个地址，你应该去读取它”。这也是你必须考虑的事情。是的，发布-订阅模式的缺点和优点完全一样，那就是事情不会立即发生。我的意思是，它们会在订阅者读取下一条消息时发生。所以作为发布者，如果你发布了一些数据，然后立即做出假设，
You make assumptions that the subscriber has read your data when that might not be true. That's a place where you can get burned, right? Yeah, if you're not careful, yep. So that's why I was saying you might make it the responsibility of the callers. If they need this data, they have to copy it out when they get the notification. Right, right. Yeah, so you just got to be careful how to handle it. So we are not the first people to talk about design patterns, obviously.
你假设订阅者已经读取了你的数据，而这可能并非事实。这就是你可能会吃亏的地方。是的，如果你不小心的话。所以我才说你可能需要让调用者负责。如果他们需要这些数据，他们必须在收到通知时将其复制出来。没错，所以你必须小心处理。显然，我们不是第一个讨论设计模式的人。
This is an established field at some level. So we have some resources for you if you're interested, people who cover this topic in far more depth, more eloquently, and with more knowledge than me, at least. And so the first one is the kind of, I guess, most famous, at least it's the one I first heard about, and it's, I guess, maybe one of the older ones to first come up with this language
在某种程度上，这是一个成熟的领域。所以如果你感兴趣，我们为你准备了一些资源，这些人比我更深入、更雄辩、知识更渊博地涵盖了这个主题。第一个是我想象中最著名的，至少是我第一次听说的，它可能是最早提出这种语言的较早的模式之一，
and have a catalog of these design patterns. And it's known as the Gang of Four because it had four authors, and it's design patterns, elements of reusable object-oriented software. It's not the most approachable book. It's not the least approachable, but it's not the most approachable book. It's not the least approachable, but it's not the most approachable coding book.
并拥有这些设计模式的目录。它被称为“四人帮”（Gang of Four），因为它有四位作者，书名是《设计模式：可复用面向对象软件的基础》。它不是最容易接近的书。它不是最难懂的，但也不是最容易接近的编程书。
I had it and I won't lie, I couldn't make it all the way through it. But that was many years ago or several years ago. So if I read it again, maybe I'd get more out of it. But it's the one that was kind of the granddaddy of them all. Yeah, I had the same experience you did where I read the beginning of it. And it was just kind of, it was too much for me. Like at the time, I just didn't.
我拥有它，我不撒谎，我没能把它读完。但那是很多年前的事了。所以如果我再读一遍，也许我能从中得到更多。但它是所有这些模式的鼻祖。是的，我有和你一样的经历，我读了开头，对我来说太多了。当时我只是没有……
It's just, it's very dense. And it was kind of written for like true enthusiasts. And yeah, I just couldn't digest it. I did read the second, like this other book, Head First Design Patterns. Yes. Which is, I did read that one and I thought it was pretty awesome. You know, it talks about all the different design patterns and detail and things like that. But it has this like, what would you describe like kind of Americana theme?
它非常密集。它是为真正的发烧友写的。是的，我消化不了。我确实读了另一本书，《Head First 设计模式》。是的，我读过那本，我觉得它非常棒。它详细讨论了所有不同的设计模式等等。但它有一种……你怎么形容呢，有点美国风情？
So it sort of has a lot of these like leave it to beaver type, you know. Yeah, it doesn't take itself too seriously. Yeah, it's kind of goofy and it's like, hey hey make sure you have apple pie with your singleton or whatever that's kind of funny um it's it's got a lot of good content it has examples which is really useful um and uh yeah that was the one that i liked the most of all of them yeah so this final one uh is actually a website that's a book called game programming patterns.com. And I saw this one posted this week. Actually, this guy finished writing this and he did one of these interesting novel
它有很多那种《天才老爹》风格的东西。是的，它不把自己看得太严肃。它有点傻乎乎的，比如“嘿，确保你的单例模式配上苹果派”，这很有趣。它有很多好的内容，有例子，这非常有用。是的，这是我最喜欢的一本。最后这一个实际上是一个网站，叫 gameprogrammingpatterns.com。我这周看到有人发布了这个。实际上，这家伙写完了这本书，他做了一个有趣的新颖方法，
approaches where I think he was publishing drafts as he was going and getting feedback and bugs filed against him and all this. So he was sharing it as he was writing it and he didn't publish it in a traditional sense. And he has a whole story about it. You can read you can read i actually didn't read the whole thing and but i was going through this and it's from the perspective of a game programmer a guy who was writing who worked at ea for a number of years writing games and saying how that in game programming there's still a lot of people who don't use design patterns and they don't think it's for them because it they're they're too manly to use design patterns or whatever and so he has
我想他在写作过程中发布草稿，并获得反馈和提交的错误报告等等。所以他在写作时分享了它，并没有以传统方式出版。他有一个关于它的完整故事。你可以阅读，我实际上没有读完，但我浏览了一下。它是从游戏程序员的角度出发的，一个在 EA 工作多年编写游戏的人，他说在游戏编程中，仍然有很多人不使用设计模式，他们认为这不适合他们，因为他们太“硬汉”了，不屑于使用设计模式之类的，所以他有
a pretty epic picture of him and his chihuahua on the front page uh okay you'll have to go see it for yourself but he has like kind of organized uh design patterns under the context of things that would be useful for a game and using games as examples. But I find that to be generally useful when I was skimming through that this week because everybody kind of understands games at some level because we've all played them. So we can imagine it versus we haven't all used enterprise software. So it doesn't make as good of an example per se. So I find that the examples here work well and he does a really good job of explaining them demonstrating their uses and giving cautionary
一张他和他的吉娃娃在首页的史诗级照片。好吧，你得自己去看看。但他把设计模式组织在对游戏有用的背景下，并以游戏为例。但我发现这通常很有用，因为当我这周浏览它时，每个人在某种程度上都理解游戏，因为我们都玩过。所以我们可以想象它，而不是我们都使用过企业软件。所以它本身并不是一个很好的例子。所以我发现这里的例子效果很好，他非常出色地解释了它们，演示了它们的用途，并给出了警示故事。
tales oh nice you'll have to check that out and it's free yeah it's pretty cool it looks like uh he's working on an ebook um so you can sign up on his mailing list to get the ebook but in the meantime you can read it all online on an html format yep well i think that's that's it for this episode yeah definitely uh you know obviously you know if you want to you know get involved in open source and other projects it's really good to sort of wrap your head around some of these design patterns you'll see them all over the place um so it won't be hard to find them but uh it might be a little challenging to know that they're there at first um it's the way to step up your
哦，不错，你得去看看，而且它是免费的。是的，这很酷。看起来他正在制作一本电子书，所以你可以在他的邮件列表上注册以获取电子书，但在此期间，你可以在线阅读 HTML 格式的全部内容。是的，我想这一集就到这里了。是的，当然，如果你想参与开源和其他项目，了解其中一些设计模式真的很好，你会到处看到它们，所以找到它们并不难，但起初知道它们在那里可能有点挑战。这是提升你的
programming to the next level that's right that's right i mean a lot of even languages like javascript um is kind of you know a lot of like client server like socket io for example in javascript has like a socket io has this concept of rooms where a room has an id and you can join a room and anyone who's in a room receives all the messages that get posted to that room but it you know like it's basically a publisher subscribe i mean what they're calling a room is really just a subscription that you can join and leave. And if you're joining, then the server publishes messages that you receive and vice versa. So, you know, you'll see the same patterns over and over again. They might have different names. They might be called differently. But, you know, reading a book like Cutverse
编程水平到下一个层次的方法。没错，没错。我的意思是，很多语言，甚至像 JavaScript，有很多客户端-服务器的东西，比如 JavaScript 中的 socket.io，它有房间的概念，房间有一个 ID，你可以加入一个房间，任何在房间里的人都会收到发布到该房间的所有消息。但它基本上就是发布-订阅。他们所说的房间实际上只是一个你可以加入和离开的订阅。如果你加入了，服务器就会发布你收到的消息，反之亦然。所以你会一遍又一遍地看到相同的模式。它们可能有不同的名字，可能被称为不同的东西。但是，阅读像《设计模式》这样的书，
Design Patterns and following our our podcast you'll be able to see them when they come up so we had some good emails so thank you for your email and your continued support of this show yeah somebody suggested design patterns ironically and I told that person I think people have suggested almost all the topics we've ever covered
并关注我们的播客，你就能在它们出现时认出它们。我们收到了一些很好的邮件，感谢你们的邮件和对本节目的持续支持。是的，有人讽刺地建议了设计模式，我告诉那个人，我想人们几乎建议了我们涵盖过的所有主题。
yeah that's true but design pattern I told him uh oh no patrick has this show picked out but we'll do design patterns next show i said that to somebody like two days ago so it turns out that uh that's what you pick so someone has uh someone knows you too well you and someone else your hearts are beating to the same drum that was actually just me oh it was your alter ego on google plus i'm just kidding but thanks for you guys for your reviews and your posts on our community on google plus and emails yeah definitely we have a facebook page that i'll be keeping up to
是的，那是真的，但设计模式我告诉他……哦不，帕特里克已经选好了这个节目，但我们会在下个节目做设计模式。我大概两天前对某人这么说过。所以事实证明，这就是你选的。所以有人太了解你了，你和其他人的心跳在同一个节拍上。那其实只是我。哦，那是你在 Google Plus 上的另一个自我？我开玩笑的。但感谢你们的评论和在我们的 Google Plus 社区上的帖子以及邮件。是的，我们确实有一个 Facebook 页面，我会保持更新，
date along with the blog and i won't lie i don't have a facebook account so you do not you still don't have a facebook account i may have one i don't know i've not logged on facebook in three four years how do you log into anything i make up fake emails and passwords oh my gosh okay um i know i know it's just a thing i don't well yeah you don't want i don't have time to keep up with the stuff i do have so yeah well i mean the bigger thing too is like everything becomes linked then right um like uh a separate discussion for another time yeah if someone compromises my facebook account now they have everything so i'll get to work oh man it's good oh man did man. Just a really quick thing.
还有博客。我不撒谎，我没有 Facebook 账号。你没有？你还是没有 Facebook 账号？我可能有一个，我不知道。我已经三四年没登录 Facebook 了。你是怎么登录任何东西的？我编造假的电子邮件和密码。天哪，好吧。我知道，这只是一个习惯。我没有时间去跟上我所做的事情。所以，是的，更大的问题是所有东西都关联起来了，对吧？比如……这是另一个时间的单独讨论。是的，如果有人现在入侵了我的 Facebook 账号，他们就拥有了一切。所以我得去处理一下。天哪，这很好。天哪。只是一个非常简短的事情。
And maybe we'll talk about this on the next show. But we definitely need to cover the Heartbleed OpenSSL fiasco. All right. Maybe we'll save that as a thing for the next show. But, yeah, there's many soapboxes we can get on about that one. Sounds good. All right, guys. Well, keep coding. keep using those design patterns,
也许我们会在下个节目中讨论这个。但我们绝对需要涵盖 Heartbleed OpenSSL 的惨败。好的，也许我们会把它留到下个节目再说。但关于那个，我们可以有很多抱怨的地方。听起来不错。好的，伙计们。继续编码，继续使用那些设计模式，
and we'll see you guys in a couple weeks. See you. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work,
我们几周后再见。再见。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，
but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但你必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。